[inaudible]
when it comes to defending America,
it is not enough to merely have an
American presence in space.
We must have American dominance in
space.
So important.
Very importantly,
I'm here by directing the Department of
Defense and Pentagon to immediately
begin the process necessary to establish
a space force as the sixth branch of the
armed forces.
That's a big statement.
We are going to have the air force and
we are going to have the space force
separate but equal.
It is going to be something so
important.
General Dunford,
if you would carry that assignment out,
I would be very greatly on
look at Mike Pence.
Mike Pence has this look on his face
like I'm going to be the president.
That's motherfuckers gone completely
crazy and I'm going to be the president
next.
That's is not have approval.
Look at his face.
He's got the face of a guy who knows
he's going to be the president.
I give you are about to be awarded
something.
Like if there was some,
uh,
something you were about to get and
you're like,
wow,
I worked my whole life for this and here
it is.
I'm going to get that thing right now.
I'm going to be the fucking president.
He must be like,
this guy is never going to last eight
years.
And for sure he's going to win again.
Okay,
I'm going to be the president.
So you think for sure he wins again
because is that because whoever the
Democrats decided to put in is going to
be an equal turd sandwich.
Again,
you're a super smart dude,
but you're also a brutal,
your big giant savage motherfucker.
Right?
So how many people have underestimated
you because you're a big giant savage
motherfucker.
Plenty talk stupid to you and act like
you're a moron.
I'd say equal street fights.
Two fights in the UFC.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people,
right?
And just people in general,
like they'll get snotty,
take stevie at treat young black men.
But I think there's a certain part of us
that might be doing that with him.
I don't think he is.
I think he's really good at winning.
This is,
this is,
this is not a,
not an like an endorsement of him.
Um,
no caveats necessary.
I'm horrified by this immigration policy
of separating children from their
parents.
I think that's subhuman.
His wife came out and said that was
bullshit,
right?
Yeah.
His wife's an immigrant,
bro.
His wife barely speaks English.
It's chaos,
right?
It's crazy.
I hate,
I hate all that stuff.
These are just family,
so just people love each.
You got to keep them together.
If they break the lie,
you keep them together.
Get them Outta here if you want.
I mean,
if you want to send them back to where
they came from,
if you're,
you're hell bent on that.
But taking them from their kids is
subhuman.
I mean,
it's beyond,
it's not us.
It's not what we're doing in 2018 that
aside all that aside,
he's probably going to fucking win
again,
man.
I think he's probably gonna win again.
I think he,
he gets in these confrontations with
people and they think he's adult and I
don't think he's an adult.
I think he's,
there's no way he can be as successful
as he's been.
I know he's had his ups and downs and
shit like that,
but like what?
He just,
just,
the way he was able to dismantle all
those guys in those Republican debates,
it didn't do what the fuck apart tore
him apart.
They had no business.
They had no business doing that with
him.
They just were too emotionally tied up
in his responses.
There was so much negativity and energy.
It was like,
there's all this anxiety,
like a fight where a guy's in full
panic,
you know,
you've seen like street fights,
especially guys just go in a full panic
or even just talking shit and the school
yard,
you know,
like yeah,
one guy's getting bullied.
Boy,
he's got the crowd watching him and the
other guy's like,
well,
but,
but your your fuck you man.
You know,
whatever.
He's like,
oh,
that ain't gonna work.
You know?
That's Kinda,
that's what the rest of it looked like.
Ted Cruz.
It's what they all looked like.
He's just been doing this his whole
life.
He's been talking shit his whole life,
you know?
And he's got a lot of fucking
supporters.
And if the economy keeps doing good,
man,
it's going to be a hard sell to put some
guy in there like Bernie Sanders who you
know all the right wing people think,
just want to give away all your money,
give away all your money to welfare
brats.
Even the left was protecting against
that.
Yeah,
right.
Cause there's still money.
Money on the left.
I should point out,
I know Jack Shit about politics.
It was very important to point out
anybody that ever says you shouldn't be
talking about politics.
That's crazy because anybody should be
able to talk about whatever they want.
But what I shouldn't do is give anybody
the impression that I know what I'm
talking about.
Cause I definitely don't like if you had
to get meat explained to you how
Congress and the Senate works and how
long the terms are and what's,
what's the cat,
you know what,
what they have to do.
That'd be a sloppy ass fucking
conversation.
Right?
I'm no political expert.
You know,
like Mike Pence is no MMA expert.
You know what I mean?
Like,
he probably could tell you who conor
mcgregor is.
You know,
like that's probably like we have equal
knowledge and government.
Yeah.
But still he might win just in terms of
like games.
Good.
Yeah.
It's a game.
You definitely could look what did,
what is it?
It's a fucking game.
It's a game.
It's a very high stakes,
gigantic game where you're trying to win
a popularity contest.
He Won.
What do you think of the rock
potentially becoming president?
One day that shit was,
that shit blew up and I was like,
wait a minute.
Now if you look at the current state and
it is a popularity contest and we want
somebody who can literally rock the Mike
has the gift of Gab.
Yeah.
But then you also have somebody who's
doing a monetarian shit is as famous as
fucking anyone has ever been.
Highest Pay Dude in Hollywood.
He so nice too.
Yeah.
That guy.
And you're like,
you don't,
you don't question his character.
Right Sweetheart?
Yeah.
He's a sweetheart.
You meet them in real life.
He's like,
dot.
To all these up motherfucker.
Big giant motherfucker.
I think you could do it.
He could when he could win,
especially if it was oprah's as vp and
I'm not even fucking around.
Not saying it's a good idea,
folks.
Not what I'm saying.
I'm just saying you don't think that the
rock and Oprah could win you,
but who would,
who would be?
Women would get super pissed off if the
rock was the president and Oprah was vp.
Oprah would have to say,
look,
she's potentially next in line.
That's not a bad thing.
She has mike pence nodding in approval,
but she won.
A lot of people would want her to be
president.
Oprah to be the first female president
to counter like the the first celebrity
president being trump.
Oprah counters that with the first
female celebrity president.
Ah.
See that's a big win with the Rock Vvp
in that situation,
it was tough to get the rock to take a
fucking bag cs.
I don't know about that.
That the rock is,
he's the rock.
It's tough to get him to take a back
seat.
It would be fascinating to see what
happens next.
That's what's going to be,
oh man,
how we're going to try to play this out,
how people are going to play this out,
the popularity contest aspect of it.
Cause it's just okay if it really
devolves into that,
it holds like,
and here's the other thing,
how much of his regulations are helping
w and what and what do we do now?
It has really fucked up.
Maybe permanent consequences to the
earth.
That's true too.
Right?
But what,
what stuff have they implemented other
than,
I know they did offshore drilling,
right?
That concerned a lot of people.
And it was explained better to me about
the,
the monuments and the private land.
Uh,
I've read a bunch of different,
um,
on public land rather.
I've read a bunch of different takes on
that.
And essentially what they did is bring
it back to where it was before the Obama
administration changed it.
So it was,
it was listed a certain way.
And then when the Obama administration
changed it,
they felt that was an overstep.
I don't know why and it doesn't seem to
be,
um,
they haven't started any like mineral
drills or oil drills or anything in
these areas.
I don't know what they're doing,
but I dunno.
I Dunno if they're really just trying to
deregulate things more.
They feel like the government
overstepped their boundaries or if they
really have nefarious ideas and they're
trying to like figure out a way to get
some oil out of a river will tell.
Yeah,
man.
I mean there was that one place,
we've discussed it before up in Alaska
were a lot of people were concerned that
there was going to be some drilling that
takes place near,
near where salmon live.
Like close enough that if it fucked up,
it could destroy this river when it
fucks up.
That's the probably the best way to say
it.
Right.
Because if,
if we,
if we don't do anything about it,
like say if you put a pipeline in the
earth and he pumped oil through it and
we don't do anything,
we just leave it there.
Just leave it there and we don't,
you know,
we don't visit it for 5,000
years.
What's this?
What's that going to be like?
So what does that mean?
It means you got to keep fixing it.
Okay.
So you put a whole,
you put a giant tube through the earth
and you're pumping toxic ooze out of
this tube.
And sometimes it gets into rivers and it
fucking kills everything.
And there's,
you want to run this fucking,
you want to run this tube under the
river.
Okay.
And then what are you gonna do?
Like how many every year?
Every five years when,
how long?
How often do you check in and when you
replace Shit,
how long those tubes last?
I Dunno,
they got to check it out.
I almost got into that.
What happens if there's an earthquake
and those tubes break?
Fuck City Wyatt,
how does that work?
I don't know.
Jack Shit about how they pump the oil
out.
Do you,
what were you gonna say?
Well,
it's um,
I mean it's a weird thing with,
we know for sure they're going to one
day break.
Like we're making that toxic pipeline.
And we know for sure it's going to the
earth's can just absorb it,
right.
Everything.
Fucking the roads,
everything,
everything.
Have you seen them show like,
uh,
a five year depiction of what would
happen to where bridges if we stopped
painting?
Yeah.
It looks like it happens overnight.
Wasn't there a show about this called
the life after humans or something?
Yeah.
Was that on like nat geo or discovery,
something like that,
something like that?
Yeah,
there's a bunch of spots.
Uh,
particularly look at the southern
California deadly as quick may have been
caused by oil drilling.
Jesus Christ in 33 dozen Oklahoma now
have a ton of earthquakes from fracking.
Yeah.
But how could they know this?
Cause earthquakes happen out here.
I wonder how they know this.
Hmm.
The study written by two leading US
Geological Survey,
Stein scientists in Pasadena,
shout out to Pasadena and be published
in the bulletin of Seismic Society of
America on Tuesday.
Also suggest that three other
earthquakes including magnitude 5.0
earthquakes in 1920 in inglewood and
1929 in whittier may have also been
linked to oil drilling.
Whoa.
I Dunno.
Maybe,
maybe we live in California,
right?
Both.
Maybe both.
Maybe it gave a little bump,
but it was happening anyway.
Fuck knows.
But it is.
Um,
it's weird.
That's a weird one.
The weirdest one for sure is nuclear
power plants.
That's the weirdest one because they
can't shut him off.
When you had a Shane Smith on,
he was talking about that kid that made
a nuclear reactor in his garage had like
17 years old.
He's like 22 or 23 works for the
government.
What did they do?
They tracked him by the materials that
he was purchasing,
shut down a fucking city block when he,
when he turned,
but he was doing like fusion.
Maybe he could do a,
was that he could refine uranium.
Oh Jesus.
He knew how to fucking mine it.
Get all the materials in the 17 that was
at 17 he's 22 now or 23 that's insane.
But he can take the used reactors and
basically like a handheld battery like
you'd have on an RC car that can power
an entire city for 10,000
years.
Each one of those.
That's what Smith was saying.
Well I know though,
that's what Shane Smith was saying.
This guy has that technology and of
course you know they're there to get a
little Eddie Bravo ish.
You know there's,
there's big companies that don't want to
see that happen but he supported by Elon
Musk and another other big time dudes
that want to see it happen.
Well he would be the thing you,
I don't know if once those nuclear
reactors get up and running like the old
style ones like Fukushima,
I don't know if they have like a way to
shut those down.
You know,
I think they need ironically enough,
I think they need power to shut him
down.
It wasn't that like a big part of the
problem with Fukushima where they
couldn't call it,
they couldn't keep it cool dude.
They can't shut them off.
Like that is the crazy.
They've only had them for,
if you stop and think about the amount
of time humans have been alive,
it's only been like
50 years,
60 years since like nuclear powers
everywhere.
Like what is the been the year for the
bomb was dropped.
And what was that 45 is that in 1945 I
don't know before my time.
Right.
Your honor,
when you take the bomb was dropped.
Was it 45 Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
I think that's right,
but I'm sorry I was looking up that they
shut down power plants in Florida when
the hurricane went through last year.
Nuclear power plants.
Yeah,
I think new ones they can,
I don't think they could shut down the
Fukushima one or I think it was just
damaged by the water so badly that
whatever they're shutdown thing didn't
work,
but there's no like there's no way to
shut it down now.
Now it's the fucking total meltdown
disaster.
I mean,
okay.
They've tried to come up with all sorts
of ways to store this shit.
Dee.
I think one of them was dig a giant
hole,
pour all the waste in there and keep it
frozen.
That doesn't sound good.
That sounds like a really bad idea.
You're going to put it in like this
giant Vat and they were going to have
this vat like super cooled to some like
ridiculous,
a low degree and do something,
correct me if I'm wrong,
it sounds like I'm making this up.
I've got Paul stamets could come up with
a way to fix that.
How would you fix
that?
Mushrooms eat all the nuclear waste
doing the,
he did that.
He had the Ted talk a six ways mushrooms
will save the world and it was at one of
his,
one of them was oyster mushrooms eating
away oil spills.
So he fucking has like three giant vats
of toxic waste.
I wouldn't say toxic like garbage and
uh,
they're all coated in oil and he does
different things to two of them.
And then on the third one,
he puts oyster mushroom spores in there
and they cover him.
And the other two distinct to fucking
hell.
Like they get worse over time.
Wow.
The oyster mushrooms grow and they grow
black as the oil starts to be absorbed
by them.
Then they break down every single carbon
in the oil until eventually the oyster
mushroom becomes white again and it's
fucking edible lately.
Breaks it down and these are giant
oyster mushrooms like just fucking
massive to do.
You going to get BP cocky.
They're going to,
they're going to get cocky.
Like,
look,
we spell it.
We've got some fucking mushrooms.
We're good.
You guys give us three months.
Damn.
Could you imagine a giant oil spill out
in the ocean?
And then the scientists drop like
billions of spores.
What does this gentleman know that might
not working in the ocean?
Which can you imagine if they did do it
and it did work and you see these
fucking building size mushrooms just
sucking oil out of the ocean.
That'd be awesome.
That'd be crazy.
And then they turn white and they become
edible and then just got to figure out
how to do that with psilocybin and we're
golden.
Wow.
Yeah.
That would be an easy fix to find some
way to blend the two of them together.
Don't Crongo crossbreed could they do
that?
I know they do that with plants,
right?
They gotta be able to do that.
How do they do that with plants?
Because they,
you know,
someone told me that blew me away that
there was um,
there were,
there were making pistachio trees and
they were binding them somehow or
another to avocado trees and they were
making them like grow together to make
like a sturdier branch structure.
And what I've seen do that,
you could mix trees.
I know here they have mixed trees but
they're from the same like file them.
I don't know if that's right.
They're close enough genetically
related.
But you'd have like one base of the tree
that has the roots and then different
branches on that tree grow different
fruit.
Why are you going to have four different
fruit styles on one tree?
Like peaches,
plums,
apricots,
all from one tree.
Wow.
Dude,
I had no idea you can buy that shit at
Costco.
I believe you.
I had no idea though.
I would have assumed that.
I would assume that like a tomato has to
be in a tomato tree.
You know that you can't splice it.
Tomato juice,
an apple tree tomato might not work.
But as far as fruit trees.
So would be cool though to do that and
maybe you could do that with tomatoes.
Maybe could have beef steak on one side
and cherry
on the other.
Yeah.
Right.
Possible.
You can have it all mixed up together.
Yeah.
It's just what a strange life form
plants are bizarre compared to us.
It's thing that lives alongside of us.
Queens are ar for us cleans our air like
New York without central park would be
so much grosser probably.
Right?
Yeah.
100% have to be like all the carbon in
the air.
Carbon dioxide,
all the fuck.
Just all the people breathe and everyone
around you.
There's so many people,
everyone just breathing.
You're going to like a soup of people
breathing on the subway and in buildings
and you know people are so jam next to
each other whether walking by,
they just breed in each other's air.
That is such a weird way that people
blue decided to live.
Yeah,
it is weird.
We were just out there for a product
development with on it and get to go out
to different conferences and shit.
So when not to Secaucus New Jersey and
they're like a giant supplement
conference where they have a,
it's basically like people that do the
science,
they figured out something really cool
but they're not big enough name to take
it to the masses.
So they,
we come in along with other companies,
we look for different things that are
backed by science,
piece it all together and create
something new.
So we're doing that by day and then we
head over to a New York by night and it
was cool,
but it was like,
it's a fucking mad house.
Absolutely insane to think that people
live on that tiny little island.
They love it.
Yeah,
it definitely buzzes.
It's got,
it's got it's own fucking energy for
sure.
For sure.
And it's a little hostile.
There's a hostility to that.
The comedy there is a,
it's,
it sort of exemplifies that New York
comedy,
it's always been some of the best comedy
in the country.
Like oh ways.
It's always been some of the best comics
come out in New York and a lot of them
are like super hyper aggressive.
Like a lot of them like real insult
comedians like that Kinda that style of
shitting on each other.
So like they're,
they're aggressively like that,
but it's like patrice o'neal was
probably like the best at it.
He was so fucking good and he was so
fucking good.
But he exemplifies that New York style
of,
what the fuck are you wearing man?
What the fuck is that shirt?
And then it would just be an attack.
And it was beautiful.
It was beautiful.
It was,
but it was fun.
It was all like in good fun and playful
and,
but that New York style is,
um,
it's like a harder style,
like a more aggressive style.
Yeah.
Even families talk to each other
differently there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Were shit talking.
Well,
you know,
I've tried to figure this out myself
because my grandparents were immigrants,
but I figured the way I was thinking it
is like if you really thought about the
kind of people that were taking a chance
to come across the ocean and get here in
like 1920,
like these were wild,
desperate people.
I,
this was a different kind of human,
they were there,
a wilder type of human being.
And then to go from that wild type of
human being to like a regular person in
2018 it's only been a couple of
generations.
Those places is where the people stayed.
So the people landed there first and
then all of that,
how the Polish and the Jewish and the
Italian and the Puerto Ricans and all
these different different fucking ethnic
group just piled in together.
Just buzzing.
And a lot of people went,
let's go west.
What's fucking go west?
And they landed over here and this is
why California is like a quite a bit
more mellow,
you know,
quite a bit more laid back.
And even the comedy,
the comedians are more friendly.
It's not like,
but there is a great roast battle scene
up here too.
They do those roast battle shows.
Those things are pretty God damn good.
I love the roast.
They get nasty with each other.
You guys sit in the back of the comedy
store and Talk Shit,
right?
Yeah.
We talk shit to each other,
but it's fun.
It's practice.
It's like we're making other comedians
laugh.
Awesome though.
To be a fly on the wall,
watching a bunch of comedians just talk
shit to each other.
Not even worried about other people,
not trying to make anybody laugh with
themselves.
We all talk shit and less joey's around.
Then when Joey's around,
just try to get them riled up.
When Joey's around,
my main goal is try to get them angry
about something and just does hear him
go off and that's when the magic
happens.
It's gotta be something you've got to
bring up some fucking band he doesn't
like or some food.
That's bullshit.
And next thing you know he's throwing
his arms back and he's fucking,
somebody orders the ranch sauce with
their salad.
Chicken wings.
Yeah,
just that one statement.
It's blue cheese with wings or go fuck
your mother is and it's just the way he
says it to.
So when,
when we're in the back of Joey's back
there,
we just let joey rant.
We just tried to get him riled up.
I mean we'll have conversations with
them.
It was just once I have a conversation,
but half the time it's like a game of
uh,
you know you're hanging around with the
funniest guy ever.
If you can get that guy to laugh and get
that guy to make everybody laugh,
just fucking poke and prod.
Yeah,
just have fun with them.
But he would always do that.
Like no one could figure that out.
We do these gigs in the road and right
before joey would go on stage,
she get mad at us.
He'd get mad at me for whatever reason.
He goes,
you got what?
This fucking laptop and this bull shit
in the fucking grip.
Pick the fucking grain ground breaking
from Beta Green Room.
So what are you gonna do?
You're gonna show me a dick.
Are you going to do it?
And he would like go into this thing
like how,
how deep you're going to get into these
fucking internet life left these fucking
people behind the scenes would just go
off and they were like,
why is she,
why is Jojo man,
but he's can fire it up to go on stage.
So he does comes back.
He's not mad at you cause this.
He just decides like this is what it's
going to be.
Ambassadors like I'm just to do some
emails
just streaming on on Youtube.
What's his deal?
What the fuck is this drain been?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck are these kids doing?
What the fucking stream and the next
thing you know,
boom,
Bang.
Everybody's on the floor dying,
laughing.
He would get fired up and then you go on
stage already at 10 you know,
is it really smart thing?
Just get mad.
Just get annoyed right before you go
onstage.
Just get annoyed at anything.
What kind of fucking mustard is what
cut?
Joe Rogan.
What kind of fucking mustard is this?
Back in jersey,
they had the mustard,
put the seeds that fucking brown,
dirty mustard oil.
Ivanka came out of someone's ass hole
and he would just,
whatever it was,
he would just start ranting about it and
get angry and then he'd go on stage like
at 10 so it could be anything,
man.
It can be a fucking TV show.
The Tahani,
he doesn't like.
It could be the pair of sneakers.
You're wearing.
It could be.
I don't like the way you're doing your
notes.
He'll just say,
he yelled at me once for having a
notebook.
I came to the Improv,
had a fucking notebook and he was 20
dude,
what the fuck and notebook.
And I go,
it's not,
that's why I keep my notes.
And he's like,
what do you want?
Everybody know you're writing.
Carry this fucking notebook around.
Get it.
You're doing it to show the world that
you're taking your job serious.
Some people do,
but I mean,
that's better than not doing it.
You know?
Even if you're like fit,
even if you're writing to fake that
you're writing all the time,
just that's definitely better than not
writing.
Carry that notebook,
man.
Courage.
No books.
I'm all,
I'm pro notebook and you guys got the
notepad right here,
dude.
You got to write shit down.
Don't look at 90% of it.
There's a lot of stuff in here that I
have no idea what the fuck I wrote,
but occasionally I feel like one day I'm
going to get it.
I'm going to be,
I'm going to wise up,
but I'm gonna go in here and I'm going
to go over these notes and something's
gonna make some sense,
but nope,
all looks like nonsense chicken scratch
of nonsense page after page of it.
Kyle Kingsbury,
do you take notes?
Like life notes?
Kind of.
I mean,
I have two journals that I use for
psychedelics ceremony,
Shit like that.
Uh,
and then my desk is,
it's kind of a fucking joke.
I mean it's just covered in postits and
I'll just jot shit down on who I'm going
to have on the podcast or the supplement
that I want to try and what dose that I
tried it at,
that kind of shit since I'm kind of the
office Guinea pig,
just any,
any bullshit,
but they're fucking everywhere.
Have you ever had an adverse reaction as
an office?
Guinea pig?
Trying shit out?
Many,
many times.
I was it a meeting with Aubrey and I
forget the guys that were there,
but there was some big wig guys and uh,
you know,
I show up and he's like,
hey,
you doing all right?
And I was like,
ah,
no,
I'm not doing good.
And I had taken,
um,
I'd taken this form of Berberine that
lowers blood sugar,
kind of works like metformin.
Dr Peter t has talked about that before
in your show and I'm supposed to help
ketone production
and just inflammation,
all that good shit.
But I took way too much.
I kind of eyeballed it.
She said,
I got cocky,
cocky.
Yeah.
I've probably had three times the dose
and it just fucking sunk me.
And I'm like,
I'm already in Ketosis.
I should be fine.
And I went pale as a ghost.
And he's like,
why?
Uh,
[inaudible] got a couch in his office.
He said,
why don't you just lay on the couch for
a minute,
you know?
So I laid down there fucking full body
sweat,
it got worse.
And I just listened and then I was like,
ah,
yeah.
It kind of close to fucking throwing up.
But uh,
and that's like one of probably 10.
How can you eyeball things?
You're a smart guy.
That's true.
Well,
I've Shit my pants or my ball and mct
oil multiple occasions.
So we talked about that last bought
house.
Dude's got so mad.
Yeah,
I'll try your dart and shoot my fucking
pants mad and not take mct oil.
You don't have to.
Or you can do it intelligently and
fucking measure your dose and not get
Ballsy,
you know?
But if you're,
if you're in the average human being,
let's just say you're an intelligent,
let's be super honest about this.
If you're an intelligent,
healthy person that eats a reasonably
balanced diet,
you still have a 1% chance of shitting
your pants every day.
And you think it's that high?
No.
Cause that's the one day out of every
hundred.
Yeah.
That's like three times a year.
No,
I have to revise my number,
maybe one 10th of 1%.
One in 1,001
in a thousand days.
So if it's one and a like one in three
years,
you've got to,
there's a likelihood I think I'm living
right.
If I shit my pants once every three
years,
if for you,
glad you said that,
not me.
Yeah.
If I don't,
if I don't push the envelope and you're
not taking that chance.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm not playing it safe.
Nope.
Not playing it safe.
That's odd.
Yeah.
It's weird that certain foods that are
good for you.
We'll also make you shit your pants if
you do it wrong,
so like your body wants this real nice
balance.
I want a real nice balance of nutrients.
Don't get fucking crazy with this stuff.
Come on.
Don't go crazy with that.
What's all the oil?
What does it look?
How did you want diarrhea?
You want diarrhea,
motherfucker.
Wow.
Your body just says,
I'm not dealing with this.
Let's just flush it out.
The problem is that you think it's a
fart and you should know better.
You know?
It's like,
oh,
that feels like air.
We're good to let this out and then it's
not so much underwear.
You can walk.
Not Good.
Then you've got to drive home with your
hips off the seat the whole way.
It's good exercise though.
For your lower pelvic [inaudible]
activate,
loosen up the front side it mail key
eagles.
You're kind of doing a Kegel,
holding it back.
Yeah.
You are definitely.
Just stay in puckered for an extended
period of time,
like women to do that competitively.
Do you know that there's like
competitions,
the golden carrot?
Yeah.
Those are some dedicated people.
Like I would imagine most girls are like
Regina is great by itself.
You don't really have to squeeze it
until come some muscular.
You can't train itself.
You can't,
you know you can't,
but how many trained in the brain you
can,
but how many people do it?
I would like to know,
I believe if there was an anonymous
thing where women can answer,
I bet that 1% how many of them squeeze
their pussy all the time and just do
exercises.
Like look at this girl.
She's got some stuff up or Punana and
then she's carrying weights around and
she's doing yoga record padding,
vaginal weightlifter.
What's wrong with the pants?
Well,
there's a hole in the middle of it where
that rope goes through.
That's one thing.
It's,
that's a rough looking rope.
Tude man,
that's like a rope that you would,
you would tie like a dog to a tree with
this.
That's all I got.
Silk Rope.
That's a fucking rope,
man.
He's not bad.
I don't,
I really don't like the pants.
This is,
it's nice that she's moving through
different positions.
You know?
She's not just standing there hitting,
she gone with it in there.
She's,
she's actually,
she's working it.
This is the sexual equivalent to you
taking that overdose of those pills or
of the of that you were taking?
The powder.
Actual equipment is exactly the sexual
equivalent because you don't want to get
jerked off by the hulk.
Okay.
I don't know.
I can't knock it until you've tried it.
I would just,
I would enter that and roll the dice and
see how strong that is.
What does she grabs it like your fist
and you're like,
oh Jesus.
She's like Pie may when he takes the arm
cocked back wrap,
but longstanding grabs it like it hurts.
Like,
hey,
well it's still going to be wet,
right?
Hopefully.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean everything seems to be in working
order.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing to want to be able
to do to carry the most weight with your
pussy.
How cute you look to see what,
how did it go from that being a thought
in your mind to one day I'll be the
queen.
One day I will care the most way to like
put it a putting it on youtube and
figuring out a way to put it on youtube.
We have pants that have a hole in them
somewhere.
Yeah,
but I'm willing to bet that seed was
planted early on in life.
Probably too early maybe.
I Dunno man.
Different strokes for different folks.
Right.
If that's true to doing,
some people play tennis.
Some people are world record pussy wait
holders like what the fuck man.
Okay.
If dudes could grow their dicks first.
Sure.
If there was an exercise that you told
me Your deck,
you've talked about that,
but their tribes in Africa where they
hang shit from there they got a penis
head piercing and they hang different
weights from their cock.
There is some of that,
right?
It's stretch it out like it's the same.
They do like Dick Games where though
there'll be semi hard and they kind of
work those muscles on top of the cock to
flex the the weight up and down,
Huh?
Yeah.
But if that was like a straight forward
site,
the penis has to be a wrecked in order
for it to be hard and if it's erect and
holly,
if it's not a muscle you could work out
and who has what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
It's more about just stretching it.
Yeah.
Like,
but if you had a weightlifting exercise
for the Dick,
like a bicep curl you how big the
fucking line at the gym would be.
If someone invented that,
no one would be wait in line for the
stair master right there would be
waiting in line to get on that dead Dick
Building machine.
All these dudes are their pants around
their ankles stuffed into a glory hole
with a some kind of weight on the other
side proportionately.
Like what percentage of girls that lift
weight go immediately to boody
exercises?
Is it a hundred it's got any kind of
squat rack or anything crazy yet.
That's where you're going to find the
girls that really want to put on that
booty mass.
Right?
It's like a high percentage.
Do you think the Dick strengthener would
make it shorter and fatter?
It would be dick strengthening gyms
everywhere.
But what it turned you into a coke can?
No,
I think it would.
Uh,
it would,
it would have to be like you could grow
it out like you could eat.
He could actually create more tissue.
What is this?
What he's showing us?
I can't find the name of this movie.
I guys trying to hang like Asian weights
from his Dick.
They got like all these cattle bells
hanging from his deck and the girl's
like,
I can't believe this.
Oh,
what is the name of this movie again?
I couldn't find the name of it.
It's gotta be a parody,
but she's got to keep them hard.
There's a black guy looking at him like,
what the fuck are you coming over there,
Dan?
That keeps stacking kettle bells on his
dick.
But if there was something like that,
like something like a glute ham machine,
you know,
something that just targeted the deck,
you should talk to rogue.
I don't think it's going to work and
you'd have one in here.
I probably would start playing with
prototypes.
Fucking a lot of people are going to
send you one.
If anybody's going to figure it out,
it's going to be Ben Greenfield.
It's probably going to be some fucking,
well,
you know,
I had them on,
on its podcast after,
uh,
after he was on yours the first time.
And I was like,
you know,
what do you want to talk about?
And we're in the Sonnet on it and I'm
like,
I want to talk stem cells.
And he's like,
listen,
no more dick stem cell talk.
I was like,
why?
you're fucking,
he goes,
no,
I don't want to be known as the Dick
stem cell guy.
And I was like,
well yeah,
you went on the wrong show.
But uh,
you know,
I still,
we still talk stem cells and obviously,
you know,
we were chatting before the show.
It's fucking Rad.
It's very cool.
We got to talk about,
um,
the intravenous stem cells that he did.
Oh,
Jamie's
show me some more dudes tying weights to
the end of their dicks on youtube.
Oh God.
Jamie,
this is not good.
Oh come on.
Oh that's at the base of his cock.
And he was holding onto the shaft while
he was
oh man.
And then he gets up and he,
he like gives blessings to everybody.
Blessings.
I carried the large walk with my cock.
Yes.
To learn it as part of that video.
You can have that when like fate or
after it's over.
No expression on the face.
Just like,
yeah,
I know what I can do.
The weirdest way to pick up a rock with
your Dick and then end it.
Once she gets up he's getting dirt to it
or something.
Well,
um,
is that writing,
is that Indian?
Uh,
is that Hindu?
Hindi,
Hindu.
Is the religion Hindu?
Is the writing?
Is that what it is?
Um,
look how they just allowed to show his
cock and balls.
I think it's cause it's like,
cause its nature,
it's a feat of strength there.
Another video I did not pull up that was
direct,
like showing you how to do this kind of
stuff with weights and Kudos to youtube
for allowing us look at this.
He just grabbing the honker at the very
end.
He's got the rope wrapped around the
middle and homeboys just going to pick
up this rock.
He's got to widen that squat stance.
Yeah,
I'll give this blessing.
Have the cock of death blessings he's
got,
he's figured out a way to lift weights
with his Dick,
like he's actually doing it and he
seemed to be a wreck there.
People seem to be there to see him.
Two children,
he's famous.
He's a famous Dick Week guy.
Do you think he has pupils?
Was He,
will he take on deciding what a great
reality show that would be?
He has to,
he can't take that to the grave with
them.
Yeah.
You have some dude who was born with a
small penis and you send him to this
guy,
to the master apprentice in India,
and he just starts going through all the
rituals,
the stones and the Deq and the sticks,
and there's gotta be more to it.
Oh,
look at these guys.
I've seen this price using weights to
enlarge your penis there swinging.
Oh Christ.
That looks like 10 pounds.
Don't say two five pound plates.
Is that Bolo Chong from bloodsport.
Oh,
that's a woman.
Oh Wow.
They're not moving their hips.
They're not at all using the Dick there.
They're using Dick Muscle.
That is so crazy.
So they have something tied to their
Dick.
We can't see it because they have some
sort of a skirt over it.
For people that are listening,
it literally looks like a skirt and then
the rope is making this weight swing
like a pendulum in between their legs
and they're,
they're not using their hips.
They're doing it all with their Dick
Muscles.
Now they're practicing kicking in the
balls.
Very important to let a guy kick you in
the balls.
What?
This guys blow testicles all the time.
Right.
I know at least two or three guys that
were kicked and blew out a testicle in a
fight or no,
mostly
I heard of it in training.
I mean,
I'm sure it's probably happened in
fights too,
but uh,
definitely in training one of the,
one of the military guys,
like a real promising kid had it happen
to them.
I'm trying to place his name.
Did it end his career?
I do not know God.
Um,
I really apologize for not remembers.
Now I want to say Brian Foster to do it
was his fault and you,
I've seen a long time,
but in training he got uh,
he got kicked,
kicked low.
Uh,
he didn't have a cup on.
It's like one more round one with that
kind of deal.
Okay,
we'll spar one more round.
Fuck it.
And wham.
I never understood that when guys
wouldn't work.
Cups and sparring.
So crazy.
Don't roll the dice there.
It's too risky.
Did you wear it everywhere?
It's tie steel cup.
Cain was big into that,
but I didn't like that it went up.
Your asshole.
You know,
it was like,
ah,
I don't know about that.
Plus they're smaller,
you know,
like they don't like the American ones
come stairways to brag.
I'm just saying,
I'm just saying they were,
it looked like it looked like it'd be in
a tight spot.
That's all.
Yeah.
Well you can't make a cup for 140 pound
Thai guy and then make that same cut fed
on gorillas like yourself.
Just need a bigger cup.
It's just part of just your gloves.
I liked it.
There was a little bit of space.
That's all I'm saying.
Do you have,
um,
is it like that leather thick padding
around the edges of it?
No.
So like when it goes into you,
it doesn't go into it straight.
It was like the rubber with a hard
plastic,
like a baseball Kabaddi guys like those.
There was this dude Amea rent of Rd.
He was one of 'em Bas rutten's proteges.
And we used to train with them at
Eddie's place and he'd mount you and he
had that fucking steel cup and it would
be like he was crushing your sternum
with his Dick.
It was uber uncomfortable who's not fun.
He was very good at that.
He would get mount on you and just crush
you down like you like unnatural
leverage in arm bars as well.
When you go over that Steel Cup,
like you got a metal thing that you're
bending someone's arm against,
it's a big deal.
It's a really big deal.
If you think about it.
I mean you would think like,
wait a minute,
I go even a regular arm bar,
hold on.
You're pulling his arm into your balls
like what the fuck?
Yeah,
you are.
You are your Dick and balls are resting
on someone's arm when you give them an
arm bar that has just a fact.
If you don't like that fact,
your goal in fact is to get your Dick
and balls to rest on this guy's arm,
but you're not thinking about that.
You're thinking of getting your hips
down on him,
getting that arm in between your legs or
getting to a arm in between your arms
and your legs,
extending your body.
But if you have any steel cop dare you
got this crazy fulcrum.
You get this weird leverage point and
it's made out of metal.
It's a fucking metal piece.
So instead of having vulnerable balls,
you have this thing,
you know,
you have like a lever,
you could snap shit better.
Mike Swift popped my rib out two days
before a fight with his cup.
This one right here.
Damn.
It still fucked up.
Yeah.
Reset that way.
Wow.
It's from those Goddamn Steel Cups,
right?
Yeah.
I mean this wicked teen and just dug
his,
his cup was writing under a rib and I
was dead tired last,
last round of training of the entire
fight camp and popped it out.
I wonder how controversial I'm so out of
the loop when it comes to grappling
[inaudible] grappling competitions.
I wonder,
um,
how legal they are.
I wonder if they're allowed to use them
at all.
I wish.
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't think they get to,
to use cups if any sort and it to sort.
Yeah.
Without the crazy.
I would want to wear a cup.
I've,
I've been smashed and then nuts before
in training.
I don't want to get to,
I don't think it's a loud wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
No cups at all because of that fulcrum
point probably.
Yeah.
Must Be.
It's crazy that your dick would become
an advantage,
like you know,
like that area instead of like being
like one object changes what that is.
So it goes from being like a super
vulnerable area to Ooh,
if I get you there,
you know,
even like north south,
like Cain and happy in north south and
just fucking digging into the side of my
face.
Oh Jeez.
And I'm sure his ball sweat there too,
but I mean really that no,
they would fuck me up.
Yeah.
You got a metal bar driving in your
face,
a real piece of metal and if you kicked
those fucking things,
you pay for it.
Like if you kick those things and you
slap it with your instep,
ah,
ah.
It's like you might as well be kicking a
rock or kicking the bottom of someone's
elbow.
Worse than young Jamie and running down
the mountain and his vibrams.
Yeah.
Young Jamie tried to go barefoot shoe
running.
Which one did you go?
Did you get the vivo barefoot or get the
vivas?
Yeah,
super thin.
Super,
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got checks.
I have two different pairs of those.
I got one that has like a lot of tread
that's like a got a good thick amount of
tread and then another one that has less
and the the one that has less like you
could feel the difference when you run
like these real slippery steep slopes.
I need something where I can dig in if
I'm trying to like sprint up to the top
of the hill and I don't want to be
worried about my footing.
I want to be able to,
I'm tired at that point too.
I'm going all the way up this fucking
dude or they toe shoes or they have full
coverage,
full coverage.
So yeah,
I like that better for for running.
Yeah.
You know you stub your toe on Shit,
you can't watch where your,
you have to like when I wear,
I liked the Vibram,
so where am all the time?
I don't have an endorsement with any of
these people.
I don't have any kind of deals,
but the,
what I like about the vibrams is for
sure it feels like you,
you're moving more with your pinkies,
like your pinky toes and the other toes.
They're,
they're like,
they were aware that they have a job.
Whereas I feel like when I wear it,
even barefoot shoes that have full
coverage,
I feel like they're like,
they're lazy.
They're just along for the ride.
Yeah.
We'll just take,
we'll just take a break.
Yeah,
we'll take a break,
but was,
whereas I feel all that shit activated.
It might be just in my head,
but when I run with five finger shoes on
a trail run with those things on,
I feel like my foot is moving just a wee
bit more than even regular barefoot
shoes.
Something about having all those little
fuckers free like that and they feel
their feeling and dirt the way they're
supposed to.
Like they're,
they're,
they're moving together the same way
your hands moved together when you grab
all your fall and gravel or something
like that,
your hand,
you know,
it moves together.
It's,
it's,
it's thinking of how to cushion blows
and how to stop something that's coming
your way and how to,
how to interact with,
with space.
Where's your footage is kind of clubbing
the ground all the time.
I feel like with those shoes,
the one thing I'm aware of is that the
foot is acting like as in it,
all the little individual muscles are
helping to push me around.
You know,
it's massive.
I've noticed that on,
I mean I'll walk wearing them right now
I'm at where I'm all the time right now.
No one's mother fucker walks around with
them.
Yeah.
Once I started walking him on a longterm
basis,
especially doing longer walks and jugs,
like there's a clear cut difference.
You have to be mindful of every fucking
step you take.
Especially if they're thinner sold,
you know,
they make some fix old ones for,
for trail running and whatnot.
But yeah,
I use those.
I only,
the only time I use the really thin ones
are at the gym.
But yeah,
those are the ones I have.
Jamie there,
uh,
you just got watch out for like sharp
rocks.
Then I don't have to watch out for sharp
And the other ones,
like if I'm running in,
something's kind of funky and it's,
I gotta go,
Ooh,
I don't want to land on that.
I gotta look,
you gotta pay attention.
Yeah.
But with those other ones,
I could just kind of hustle and breathe,
but maybe that's not as good.
Maybe it's better to do it that way.
You know,
maybe it engages your brain more forces
you to think and make decisions while
you were exhausted.
Actually,
it might be better now that I'm thinking
about it.
It might be a better thing to do as a
workout.
You're more present to,
you know,
you have to get about other bullshit.
It's kind of like,
you know when we're talking about our
tree or the cold bath or any of these
things it tells you in,
but to,
I think part of it for some people with
running is like that getting into the
zone thing
that you do,
you know when you start getting a pace
going and just get into that zone when
you don't want to think about any other
extraneous shit.
And if you're doing that and watching
every step you take,
is there,
is it possible,
I'm just throwing this out there that'll
would like inhibit you from getting to
the zone cause you'd have to be too
conscious about every step you're
taking.
Maybe.
I mean,
I'm sure everyone's different,
right?
But for me,
when I do that,
I don't feel,
I feel like it draws me into the zone.
Right?
Because if I can just run on a fucking
treadmill,
I'm not worried about where my feet go,
that kind of thing.
And then my mind will wander then.
Right.
Because I don't have to pay attention
and it'll start thinking about other
shit,
especially if it's an easy run.
Hmm.
My mind will wander then it's not dialed
in because it doesn't have to be.
Yeah.
What kind of cardio machines do you use,
if any?
Well one that I really like.
I mean all I can use right now cause my
niece fucked is the ski Erg and I that
Aubrey and I'll get
on those and do some sprint work.
We're saying you have a,
was it an MCL tear or torn meniscus?
Yeah.
Thankfully no surgery required with that
cause the placement.
But and so you got some stem cells on
that?
Yeah,
we did stem cells.
What did they do last week we did a
umbilical stem cells intra-nasal a I v
and in the knee with Gouda town.
Jesus.
The new,
the needed hurt.
Like I thought the fucking injection was
going to hurt.
Like they are going to wiggle it in with
some long ass needle,
but that wasn't bad.
The pressure,
once it goes in,
that fucking hurt,
um,
stem cells fixed my left knee,
I was having problems with my left knee
for years.
I had a acl reconstruction on that knee
and on that knee.
Um,
they took some meniscus out as well.
It's always been a problem.
Like whenever I would work out real hard
look two or three days in a row,
it was always sore.
Like I'd walk around and was just sore.
It was B and then I have to warm it up
to get going one session with a
umbilical cord stem cells and then I
gave it a long time off and I never had
a problem with it again.
Like you literally went away.
It's like one of those things where I
had a problem.
Now I don't have a problem anymore.
Like he'll running,
kicking the bag,
whatever I'm doing.
Uh,
using that echo bike or the versaclimber
anything I'm doing with my knees,
no problems.
I'm just babying it now.
But we work with this guy Dr.
Craig conover who did the stem cells.
He's been doing a vitamin IVS at a on it
for us and he's a fucking savage.
We'll do like the ntd treatments in Nad
socks about.
Greenfield was telling me really,
really it is official yet as fuck.
Tell me about it.
It feels like we get it done at an ivy.
What's the name stand for again?
I think it's nicotine [inaudible] at an,
I had a dean at Dennis saying,
I don't know nicotine identity at Dennis
seen die nucleotide.
There we go.
Damn.
Anyways,
it's a fucking,
it's,
it's basically food for the Mitochondria
and you can influence that pathway
through fascinating hot and cold
therapy,
a high intensity intervals,
different things like that,
but just to get it mainlined into your
fucking body,
it feels like someone's got their hand
on your stomach and they're slowly
turning it.
It doesn't feel good.
You fucking sweat.
If people have nasal issues,
they'll sneak it.
Feel like it's turning your stomach.
Well,
I think the idea is that because it
influences mitochondrial biogenesis,
it's going to kill off any old
mitochondria that needed to go,
but you want that in the gut and then
you get new ones and over time,
I mean,
we front load this a four to eight days
in a row and by the end of this,
I mean like front row front,
load it every single day.
You do it for eight days.
Why then you only need it like once a
month or once every two weeks after
that.
Right.
Little touch ups after every single day.
Every single day you're getting gut
wrenched.
Yeah.
But by the end of it,
you feel better.
So because you've gotten rid of most of
the bad shit.
And again,
that's theory.
It's not,
I mean,
this is brand new stuff here.
We've got to be pseudo sciences on rats.
Let me,
let me say that this is the science
side.
Rats is always like a weird thing to
say,
but I'll tell you that the feeling,
the feeling is,
is there's no fucking dot.
It works.
I mean,
anything that influences mitochondria
influences everything.
That's energy for your brain.
Cognitive function,
heart,
lungs.
The whole nine Greenfield was saying
that he had the Mitochondria,
the like the telomere lengths and they
check his telomere length.
That is biological age was 20 so he went
from,
he went,
he started,
yeah.
And listened to him.
He had the Telo years guy on right.
And that's,
so I did the same test and his
biological age was 36 and his
chronological age was 34 and I'm like
this motherfucker who was homeschooled k
through 12 and it's an Ironman
triathlete is two years older
biologically than chronologically.
Where the fuck am I went to Asu?
Did all the bad drugs get hit in the
head fucking countless times.
I gotta be,
it's gotta be bad.
So at 35 when I did mine a biological
age of 41 and I'm like fuck.
So,
but right after he did the systemic stem
cells through the ivy that dropped him
from 36 to 20 years old biologically.
And,
and how many did he do?
How many sessions did he do?
I don't know.
I think it was just after the first one.
I know he's done a more and he did
different stem cells.
So why you,
why are you guys doing it so many days
in a row for the Ntd?
Yeah.
Well,
the idea of front loading,
you know,
they used to say that with creatine.
I think that's been debunked,
but there are certain substances,
especially with how they influence,
you can really ramp up and change the
body dramatically.
And then after that you just need little
touch ups here and there.
But uh,
you know,
I just feel like,
what'd you feel like after with the ned?
I was,
I was like,
I know,
I want to know,
really be able to look at this like a
quantified self,
you know,
I'm not going to be able to take numbers
and shit.
So what I did was I put myself through
the meat grinder.
I hadn't really been trained in a lot
and uh,
since you know,
working my first real nine to five kind
of thing.
And um,
I train twice a day,
busted out the old altitude machine was
doing altitude every day,
hot and cold,
you know,
he got the dual sauna on it.
I do the cold bath at home and all
during that process because we've got
the little,
the little guy,
I wasn't sleeping well,
so put myself through all that.
My fucking cardio went through the roof.
I never got sick.
I recovered well.
So I knew it worked.
And on top of that,
you know,
cognitive function,
memory,
retention,
everything was fucking scaling up a
notch and cardio.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Your cardio ramped up.
Anything that influences mitochondria
affects fucking all of it.
That's ATP throughout your entire body.
And it's brain too.
You know,
people think of like,
all right,
that's one of the,
one of the reasons they're looking at
Korea team right now as a nootropic
because he influences atp and the Bra,
every fucking thing in your body runs on
ATP.
How have they done studies on this yet?
Uh,
I think greenfield might be a better guy
to ask,
but I'm,
I'm pretty certain that they verified
that creatine helps,
helps the brain.
Now it makes sense if it helps muscles,
I mean,
if,
if it helps blood
flow,
I mean,
I mean there's,
there's gotta be a bunch of different
things.
It's energy,
it's seller cellular energy.
ATP is right.
So everything runs on that one thing and
you're good there.
Whether you're in Ketosis or you're
eating carbohydrates,
it's all going back to ATP.
It's crazy.
You could do that.
You could have someone inject something
into you and all of a sudden you get
this like this recharge state.
And then there there's the debate.
Okay,
is this healthy?
Has it,
what's the long term?
Well yeah I and then all this shit.
You know,
it's funny because some of the
drawbacks,
I have a certain amount of followers
online then you know,
you go to a company like on it and you
have,
it's magnified right by a hundred by a
thousand,
whatever.
And uh,
you know,
anytime I post shit,
cause I'll do stuff online for like the
bio hack of the week at the life hack of
the week.
And sometimes it's just run of the mill,
you know,
go for a fucking farmer's walk with some
weights in your hand or keep a
Kettlebell in your trunk and then you
can always work out whatever.
Or sometimes it's more technology based
and we,
we get a lot of shit on anything
technology based.
And of course the argument then is,
well,
I,
I believe I can get everything I need
from a good diet and good nutrition and
movement and I don't need to inject shit
to be healthy.
And it's like,
yeah,
but I like greenfields model,
you know,
like you have one foot and then sister
living in one foot in the benefits of
modern science.
Yeah.
So why wouldn't I fuck with that?
I think that's a smart way to approach
it.
I think we have a real problem and we
always have,
uh,
as human beings being tribal,
and I'm on tribe natural,
I'm all natural bro.
You know,
don't take,
I'm not into hormones.
I'm not,
you know,
I don't need my cell phone man.
I'd rather leave it alone.
And then we've got tribe science who
think that,
you know,
that science is going to figure
everything out and nature ain't shit.
And just,
we're better than nature.
We're smarter than nature as forward.
That's obviously the extremes of each
end,
but people just tend to fucking do that.
Man,
there was the most ridiculous video that
I retweeted from barstool.
I think it was barstool just find out
who I retweeted it from.
So we'd give him credit on their
instagram,
but they,
it was a,
was it barstool?
It was a video at a baseball game and
one side was saying right fields sucks.
And the other side was singing left
field sucks.
And they would yell it out on twitter.
Here we go.
One,
two,
three socks and everybody got pumped up
and then the people over here like
leftfield stuck.
People are so stupid.
They will,
they will.
The team,
that side on the left side is the burst.
Like here it is.
Play this is it a Barstool barstool
sports.
Shout out to Barstool sports on
instagram.
Look at it.
[inaudible] we're not going to take,
but
say if I was there,
I would enjoy every second of that.
Especially if I had a couple beers in a
hot dog in me I had been yelling at too.
Yeah,
man.
I mean that's,
that's what's fun.
Right?
And they're all rooting for the same
team.
Who knows?
How do they do that?
Yeah,
no,
but they don't fucking split the sides
on,
on a home.
Does anybody ever again.
They do that and soccer,
it might happen.
There might be a section,
but there's still people all over the
place.
But for both teams.
Yeah.
So they're not rude on the same team,
but like conceivably they could just go
the hall that it proved my point even
further though,
because now you have both,
you know,
say it's cubs and,
and a giant,
right.
Cubs fans and giants fans sitting on the
right field,
both yelling to the left field to left
field sucks.
Yeah.
And cubs and giants fans on left field,
both yelling at to right field.
It's bringing people together.
Joe Rogan to hate.
Yeah.
For at least it's fake hate.
You know,
they don't really think those people
suck.
I,
if you're out sat them down as
individuals and said,
what do you really think about these
random people on the right?
Like,
Oh,
they're just folks that are sitting over
there watching the baseball game.
Is this a parallel for politics,
for life,
my friend,
for all of this life?
I don't know.
Probably.
Right.
It's probably something to that.
That might be also why trump could win
again.
He can,
when he up,
anybody that believes that he won't win
again.
They're the same people that believed.
He stood no chance of winning.
The first time did I took a photo of
Jake Tapper on TV when the results were
being read because he was,
you know,
doing one of them report things and he
had the,
through the entire election,
he was like really very,
very obviously,
uh,
in an angst at the thought of this guy
being president.
And then when he finally became
President Jake Tapper's face,
it's just like,
it's so classic.
It's,
it's one of those moments where you like
cheese Christ.
I'm never going to forget that guys face
when trump was elected because it was
just like,
what the fuck is this?
It was just a crazy face.
I mean,
if everything works out,
nobody dies.
No extra people die because of trump
being president.
This will be a very fascinating time to
study,
be a very fascinating time.
I don't think there's ever been a time
like this man,
drug laws are relaxing all over the
place.
They're,
they're pushing MTMA through maps is to
get it to use use for therapy for
soldiers with PTSD.
And it works remarkably well.
It works better than fucking anything.
I've been able to guide a couple of
those sessions.
Couple's therapy sessions,
not the PTSD sessions have been like,
ah,
fucking incredible.
I mean,
I watched a breakup happen with that and
I've never seen people break up prior to
that.
So I don't really have the,
but just seeing
it,
it's hard opening medicine,
you know,
and I know that you haven't had great
experiences with it in the past,
but this pharmaceutical shit is a whole
different animal now.
Have a bad experience.
I only had a bad experience with the
com,
the company.
There is no come down with the
pharmaceutical.
I mean fucking zero and I mean
diminishes your um,
your,
your dope.
I spoke to,
I've spoken to Rick Doblin about this
twice.
Serotonin levels.
Yeah.
And the thing is,
you know,
as with any is,
I know it's not a true psychedelic,
but with any psychedelic,
what was the true psychedelic,
true psychedelic like Marco Polo say
would be like a trip to mean based
psychedelic,
the classical psychedelics.
You look at,
um,
hallucinations.
Yeah.
And you're,
you're thinking of things like
mushrooms,
Lsd,
you know,
watch Chuma,
pod,
Iowasca dmt.
Those kinds of things would be more
traditional.
You know what,
man,
I would,
I would honestly say that I think in
high doses,
edible marijuana is a psychedelic.
Yeah.
There's no doubt.
No doubt.
I really,
I mean,
I've heard people argue against that.
I'm like,
fuck man.
I don't know.
I think in high doses when you're,
um,
when you close your eyes and lie down,
like sit down on a couch on a high dose,
you're really,
really flying.
I've had visuals from fucking gorilla
glue,
just smoking,
gorilla glue.
My wife and I both,
what do you mean gorilla glue?
It's a strain.
Not Actual Glue.
Yeah,
it was huffing [inaudible] with my wife.
I was like,
where I met with anything.
It's fucking podcast took a turn.
I was like,
no,
Kingsbury.
So savage,
he's out there smoking glue,
gorilla glue.
It's the name.
Yeah,
I'm not going to be a good father.
And you experienced it.
Streets it fucking full blown,
full blown.
You know you can get a man if you get
high enough.
Mckenna used to say to the way to do it
was to not get high for long periods of
time and then smoke as much as you can
handle in one setting.
That's not my jam.
I've been using a one one milligram thc
spray and I microdose cannabis fairly
often just in just in the evening and it
helps with sleep.
Uh,
but this Mtma man,
it's a whole fucking different ball
game.
I think it's interesting.
I think you should try if I can request
at some point you tried the
pharmaceutical grade Mtma just to know
what it's all about because Rick Doblin
was saying you give it,
you give it space like you would with a
classical hallucinogen.
You're not supposed to fucking go back
to work the next day or do a bunch of
bullshit,
tedious drawn back into the real world.
Give it space journal,
meditate,
throw on some easy listening,
music and rest.
And if you do that you're fine.
Because in their protocol they're not
allowed to use anything else but the
MTMA.
So I asked him like,
why don't you guys have a protocol for
five htp,
vitamin C,
different things we know help build back
the neurotransmitter support you may
have lost.
And he said just with the finagling with
the FDA and everything they have to go
through,
he says it's fucking impossible.
But if we give him that day off their
gold and then of course new mood plug on
it again was designed for that
experience to be to curtail
any kind of come down.
I've had zero issues after using the
pharmaceutical grade.
What was the original name of it?
Roll on roll off or what was it like
that?
Yeah,
it was something like that.
Yeah.
He was five htp boosters,
like I mean five htp supplementation has
been going on from a long time.
Lot of people have been into that.
It's hard.
Yeah.
It's a smart way to approach Mtma till
like to stock up to have a bunch of your
system so your,
your body is going to have to build this
shit up again because you're going to
flood it with it for awhile so you're
going to have this weird little period
where your body is going to struggle.
But it's a,
it's a thing that I would hope if this,
these studies do continue to prove
without a doubt that it's beneficial to
a lot of these people that they make it
available to more people.
It will be,
it will be,
should be quick.
They estimate 2022 I think or 2023 at
the latest [inaudible] he got a f the
FDA made a breakthrough drug I think
breakthrough drug,
which is like on the fast track to go
through.
I think the whole world would be way
better if everybody was on just like a
micro dose of ecstasy all the time.
Just a little,
just a little like Ah,
I don't know that that could last but
that would be medicine cause it's micro
dose.
That's the thing.
You talk about compassion and all these
other important lessons that have been
talked about in all spiritual texts,
it's automatic.
You drop right into that.
Yeah.
Do you think that it's possible to train
your brain to produce more of it?
Do you think through meditation and
mindfulness and all these different
practices that people do to stay
present,
to be more open,
more loving,
that you could build that up?
Almost like a muscle?
I don't know that you could build
serotonin up over time.
I'm sure there's some type of cap where
nature nature does not want us to be
happy.
24,
seven.
Is there any tricks though?
But yeah,
to like getting it to turn on,
there's a book,
uh,
the science of mindfulness by doctor
Ronald Siegel.
It's on one of the great courses on
audible and he's a harvard professor and
he talks about the brain like a fucking
muscle and sciences back this,
the more you train that,
the easier it is to drop into.
And I've had coaches,
um,
breathwork coaches,
you know,
we're working with the art of breath.
Uh,
Rob Wilson and Brian Mackenzie came out
and they did like a full fucking blown.
They have breath working on it and the
more often you can shift into
parasympathetic state from fight or
flight sympathetic,
you know,
you shift consciously through breath
into that simple parasympathetic state
that becomes trainable.
You can do that over and over again and
then all it takes is just a couple of
deep breaths in your back,
right?
Because you train that the fucking body
remembers,
the brain remembers and when you're in
those states that shifts everything from
the neurochemical response to the
brainwave state.
You can drop from Beta into Alpha into
theta.
That's fascinating stuff,
man.
It's crazy to think what we understand
about the various pathways these
chemicals have to go through and then
what is like still confusing?
Like here's the big one,
where's the,
where's the consciousness coming from?
Exactly.
How does it all become the thing
that's looking through Kyle Kingsbury's
eyes and seeing me in mind looking at
you w w what's exactly what's,
what is that thing?
What is that thing that seems to be like
almost like a,
like an energy that runs through this
machine.
It's through fucking everything.
It's in all things,
but if we thought about it that way,
like you'd be so much more concerned
with keeping that energy high,
you know?
I mean,
how much of what,
what people experience when it comes to
the,
the word depression,
how much of it is their life going?
Bad tragedy,
poor health,
bad job choices.
How much of it is some sort of a weird
genetic thing?
How much,
I mean there's so many variables as to
what causes depression,
but such a giant number of people suffer
from depression.
Well,
I think it's,
I think it only,
if I'm being honest,
I think it's going to get worse.
You know,
like you look at the way we live and the
closer and closer you've spoken about
that we were just talking about fucking
New York.
We're not meant to be that confined.
We're not meant to sit out like with
were withheld from the fucking sun right
now.
So many of these things communicate with
our bodies and working with a genetic
specialist ran for singer,
he was on Chris Ryan show sunlight
influences 500 on off switches on our
epigenetic level for the,
for the good,
unless you fucking overdo it,
right?
500 500 plus on off switches in our DNA
are affected by sunlight positively,
right?
I mean there's,
they look at vitamin D three takes that
for example,
they're calling that a hormone now,
not a fucking vitamin real is,
it's a messenger.
That's how much it influences in the
body.
Incredibly important.
So when you think about all these things
like being barefoot,
being connected to the earth,
going in the fucking ocean,
science will catch up in certain ways,
but we get fixated on the thing.
We get fixed and it fixated on our
phones,
on whatever TV is going on.
We're closed off from other people.
We think,
you know,
communicating through facebook is the
same as being fucking face to face.
It's not,
you know,
and the more we head that direction and
we're putting,
you know,
as you put it,
put in fucking shit food.
In our body from mouth pleasure that
influences the brain,
right?
80 to 90% of all of our
neurotransmitters are made by the
bacteria in our gut.
So you think the shit meals just going
to put on five pounds.
It's not.
It might put on five pounds,
but it's going to fuck your brain up for
a while.
You make you a little bit more emotional
fuck with your,
your,
your sharpness,
your memory recall,
all that's impacted.
Sleeps impacted.
I wish Michael Walker talked a bit more
about that and it's don't think it's in
his wheelhouse.
I don't think it is.
He's a,
he's just to go studies,
sleep and the effects on it.
But fuck was that in illuminating
eyeopening podcasts was so important to
me.
It was fucking fantastic.
I think his book is really good,
but as far as like dialing in sleep,
it's more of this is what happens when
you don't sleep.
Sleep,
the book,
sleep by Nick.
Little Hales is probably my favorite
because
that gives you all,
it's a fucking how to guide on how to
maximize sleep.
And when you were younger,
lack of sleep didn't affect you the way
it affects you now,
right?
Correct.
Yeah.
Everything he talks about like the,
would that shift that you have that
happens in adolescence where you become
a night owl?
No doubt.
And I probably still could stay out a
little bit later until having a kid and
then that's your,
your immediate reset bitch.
You're getting up when the sun comes up.
Yeah.
Be prepared,
sir.
Get ready.
Yeah.
It's um,
there's so many different factors that
lead to a healthy body,
but how much of a healthy body leads to
a happy mind?
That's where it gets like you can't
blame some of these people that are
suffering from like a disease.
Some of these people that have like
something wrong with the way their brain
is producing these happy hormones.
I don't think you can say it's just this
one thing like,
well if you just eat clean or if you
just went keto or Paleo,
then you wouldn't have depression.
I don't think that's it at all.
But certainly that's a factor.
It's certainly could be a fact being in
nature,
being in nature as a fact and unpacking
trauma.
Gaba Montay says at the heart of all
fucking addiction is some form of
trauma.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Completely makes sense.
Yeah.
His,
uh,
his theories on that are fascinating.
It's,
I never thought about that way.
That's some form of trauma during your
developmental stage is led you to like
seek out this weird,
crazy feeling and experience.
When you,
uh,
have,
have you known many people that have had
like serious addictions,
like meth or oh,
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
without naming names,
uh,
people very close to me.
Family members.
Uh,
I've been addicted to meth.
I lost a cousin to pills.
Um,
I've been going to Aa,
not for me,
for a family member since I was three
years old.
So I've seen that,
you know,
what if is now,
now is that trauma based is like
everything because pills don't pills
just get kind of get everybody.
Yeah.
Pills can get everybody.
There's no doubt about that.
Um,
there wasn't,
there wasn't yourself off.
There was this show with some trauma
there on a,
in all of those circumstances.
And I'm not saying,
you know,
pills can fucking grab you,
there's no doubt.
Um,
but certainly with the meth and uh,
the alcohol,
which was other things,
you know,
no doubt there was trauma there.
You have known of quite a few people
that got fucked up on,
on pills after operations or injuries or
stuff like that.
But um,
I know quite a few of them that it
kicked it,
you know,
[inaudible] just realized it was
happening when whoa down like a
[inaudible] talked about it quite a bit.
When he fought cro cop,
his nose was destroyed so they had to
rebuild his nose and he started taking
pain pills and he said after a while,
he's just taking them every day just
because we wanted to take him.
And then his friends came over and
cleaned out.
It's a medicine cabinet and like,
cut the shit dude,
you're is four months later you're still
taking these things all day long,
you can't do that anymore.
And he's like,
whoa.
He said he almost didn't even realize he
was doing it.
It just kinda caught a hold of him.
Yeah.
Shit becomes habit.
Especially when it's that euphoric.
Must be amazing.
You know what I took the other day?
I took a large dose of Kratom.
Ooh,
yeah.
Everybody always tells you that Kratom
is a one thing at a small dose,
you know,
it's kind of a two pills to me seems a
almost like a stimulant.
Like 100% yeah,
and even up to four pills,
but you're getting the land to eight
pills.
I took eight pills the other day.
I was like,
Whoa,
this I am.
Hi Mike.
I'm fully functional.
I'm not worried about the way my body
moves.
Like it's not like I'm going to fall
down when I'm walking.
Everything seems like it's working good,
but I'm clearly high,
but I'm not hiring a bad way.
Like I can talk fine.
I can remember things,
full conversations,
happy,
remember people's names,
but I'm definitely high.
Yeah.
Kratom is a funny one.
You know it's,
it's still an opiate.
It's still hitting those receptors.
It's actually an opiate.
Yeah,
I believe it is.
Um,
but what did they Hamilton Morris from
Hamilton's Pharmacopia coming on soon.
Yeah,
he's,
you know,
that's one of the things he says because
he's not spiritual.
He,
even though he does all these
psychedelics,
um,
so he gets really pissed off and people
call it plant medicine or to the agenda
and shit like that.
He's like,
you have to fucking say you call it what
it is.
Right.
I'm sure he did it.
There's a lot of that fuckery though,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
But,
but at the same time,
I mean,
you can so real and a lot of times you
can take mushrooms recreationally or you
can do the rogue dose and it be happy
guided and you can do,
I was in the Amazon and it's a whole,
it's a fucking world different.
Yeah,
for sure.
Totally different experience.
But yeah,
going back to Kratom,
thankfully I've always had this thing
with opiates where if I had too much,
I get nauseated really bad,
so I can take one or two pills and it is
a mild stimulant.
I drove to greenfields house when I was
living in Vegas to podcasts with him
thousand miles each direction and I just
have one pill every three hours.
Wow.
And it was awesome.
I was fucking,
I felt great.
So if I can heal every three hours,
just kept you focus while he driving.
And I felt there's about euphoria.
I felt good being in that little ass
Prius the whole way,
you know,
which is important.
Right.
Let me see.
I don't even know how you climb in that
day.
I got that.
I got in there,
but let's just take three or more.
I'm fucked up.
Like I'm riding that fence and gonna
Puke.
Am I going to Puke?
So interesting.
So even for you,
they have the same reaction that like an
oxy would have.
Yup.
And I've had,
I mean,
in college I did some weird shit at
keystone and oxy once and uh,
wow.
Fucking under the folks not learned in
the ways of the dirty dogs.
He put it up,
his asshole to Nicholas deep,
not super up as the people that people
are like what case stirred dudes would
just go,
oh well yeah,
last time,
last time I was on your show,
they're like,
oh,
you lost me when you told me the trees
started talking to you when I was
describing night and ios experience.
That'll be the one this time.
Do you lost me when you told him when
you stuck about putting a pillow for
your ass?
That's when they turned out the podcast.
Um,
but yeah,
I felt fucking great that one time I
tried it.
I tried to,
I snorted one later,
you know,
like a few weeks later and I was fucked
up.
I was fucking puking the whole time and
uh,
and you could suck off the,
I don't want to,
it went bad drugs.
I want to tell people how to do good
drugs.
Why would you a snort it?
Cause it goes right into your
bloodstream.
Yeah.
You know,
you can suck at that time.
Release,
crush it up,
let it dry.
Wow.
So,
but that ultimately that was like,
well,
yeah,
there's still,
thankfully I still have this fucking
regulator on my body that says don't put
these fucking super addictive manmade
chemicals in your body.
That's fascinating.
Do you think it's create a manmade,
it was sort of a plant,
right?
It is plant based.
I mean all this shit's plant based.
The issue is when we take something and
we fucking concentrate it and change it
in a way to where it just really has an
affinity for receptors and we lose out
on all these other alkaloids and
turpines and things like look at marinol
versus whole plant cannabis.
Oh,
right.
Fucking bulk.
If they take this stuff and then turn it
into an actual drug that they sell,
they're only going to sell parts of it,
right?
Yeah.
They're selling the active ingredient
like cocaine versus fucking coca leaf.
Totally different experience and it was
ever had coca tea.
They have had coca tea.
I've,
I've thrown coca leaf.
This is called,
they call it Mommy and Columbia and you
chew it.
Chew.
Yeah.
How is it an amazing,
it's like a cup of coffee though.
Like less jittery,
your brain turns on.
It's a nootropic.
You feel like 1 million bucks.
We can't catch it
because in Miami [inaudible] they fucked
us all their,
their whole city's made out of coke.
No,
that,
no,
no dude.
You,
have you ever seen cocaine cowboys?
Yes,
dude,
that's all Miami.
That,
that all that,
that area of Florida,
they're one point at one point in time,
I don't know if it's still the case,
but Miami had more banks per capita than
any place else in the country because
everybody is just laundry and Koch money
and coke is just coming in like crazy.
There's so many great documentaries on
it.
It's a really,
really fascinating time in like history,
like during cocaine.
Cowboys wants,
shout out to Billy Corbin,
the um,
the first one they talked about how many
of these uh,
police officer's wound up dead or in
jail and it was like an entire class
graduating class either was dead or in
jail for corruption.
But,
but it's something,
you know,
they had made this a look at this time
period,
however many years it was a of this
cocaine trafficking.
Who's crazy man,
like it's a incredible time and like
human history,
Ben,
this article,
it says that it's ramped back up to
those 1980s drug war heights of
production.
Whoa.
Hey,
so how's it getting in?
That's the question.
Yeah.
How are they getting it in?
I don't think that's a problem.
I don't think it is either.
But how are they doing it and how do
they,
I mean,
that's a lot of money.
Why are you so much of that money?
So much money in it that what it costs
us.
Florida customs and border protection
confiscated 4,200
pounds of cocaine last year compared to
1,730
pounds the year prior to that.
So it means the guy,
the guy that was getting paid off the
year before it got caught,
maybe.
How else are they getting it in?
I don't.
Maybe they just caught more coke the
time.
Maybe they're getting coked up and then
they're taking the boats.
They just take risks.
I know where these fucking cops hide.
I know them better than they know
themselves.
We've never seen cocaine production at
these numbers.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Stay the fuck out of Miami for a while
folks.
It could get crazy or go there or go
there.
Yep.
I liked the way you think,
dude,
into the fray.
You know,
where's the party?
Miami,
the DEA estimates Columbia produce 710
tons of pure cocaine last year or enough
to fill about 18 semi trucks.
Ah,
did you see that a so crazy.
They found the first coca farm in
Mexico.
Oh Jesus.
That can be a problem.
Yeah.
Well it actually might help with the
drug wars really.
If they can grow it and they can't fight
against each other,
they can't grow it.
Yeah.
Mexicans in Columbia has been fighting
for a long,
so they would start fighting with each
other and that would help the drug war.
They would fight less because Mexico
would have its own production.
But I mean they said it was growing in a
place that wasn't the same altitude and
obviously cocaine,
it's an alkaloid that is really it.
It grows at altitude,
so you want that,
that environmental stimulus for that.
You know,
you want the hormetic stressor in order
for it to produce more cocaine,
pound for pound,
and I think it would produce far less
that.
That's at least what they were saying in
the article,
which makes sense to me.
Why?
What's the justification for what does
this Jamie,
we show how they're getting it in.
I says speedboats chuck mills and on
poor old lady.
Look at this poor old lady.
She's holding the kilos.
She looks like she's about seven years
old,
maybe older,
maybe eight years old.
And she's fully strapped up with
cocaine.
I mean,
who could,
who could blame this lady?
Do you think she's out there hustling?
She got a pistol in people's faces.
You're the shine that that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
So we need more good drugs and less bad
drugs.
We definitely need more good drugs.
We need to do something to get this does
wave of negativity that so many people
are experiencing on a regular basis.
Do you settle that down and bring that
up?
Do you know anybody that's done ketamine
treatment?
Yes.
And pretty good results,
right?
Neil Brennan had very good results.
He liked it quite a bit.
He,
um,
he's done a bunch of different things
for depression,
magnetic things,
ketamine things.
He
said Ketamine was very effective.
Yeah.
I had a,
one of my first coaches,
a striking coach,
he had,
you know,
he'd been put on every kind of fucking
Ssri for years and just felt like shit.
And he did for Ketamine treatments and
he's down to like one Ssri off 90% of
his medication.
He said he's never felt better.
I like that,
that shitty voice that everyone has in
their head that was so loud for him is
nonexistent now.
Whoa.
Yeah.
We got to do that.
Dr.
Craig put us through a slightly
different,
most of the people that I think that are
doing ketamine treatment do at Ivy.
We had an intramuscular injection of
ketamine.
That's the John Lilly.
It was fucking insane,
like 40 minutes long.
Um,
and it was kind of tied in with the stem
cells really to just be in a state of
allowing and whatever subconscious level
of accepting this foreign substance into
your body.
Let's,
let's kind of move the needle on that.
Again,
that's theory.
Um,
what's the experience like?
What it's a psychedelic,
correct?
It is,
but it's different.
So again,
we talked about the,
the classical types tryptamine base
going to fit in serotonin receptors in
different parts of the brain.
Um,
this is a dissociative,
so it pulls you back layers,
you know,
like we talked about Eckhart toll last
time,
how he talks,
be the observer,
be the witness of your thoughts.
You're not your thoughts.
Just pull yourself back a layer and kind
of see your mind chatter as this
interesting thing like kids arguing,
right?
This will force that.
And it pulls you back layers beyond
that.
Like to the point where,
you know,
you're not in your body,
but when you reenter your body,
there's a lot of gratitude and you can
kind of see things where they are,
you know,
you,
you understand now like,
oh,
this is how I was feeling before,
but I've been removed from it long
enough to when I come back to it,
I can recognize it for what it is.
Whoa.
And I don't have depression now,
you know.
So doing it was,
it was just more of a,
let's see what happens,
you know,
kind of kind of intention as opposed to
like people that are going in there
working on shit might be a bit different
for them,
but it was fucking bananas.
Yeah.
I've never talked to,
um,
I knew a guy who got addicted to it
though,
as a,
as a street drug,
as a party drug.
You know,
some people have snorted half's in order
to,
yeah.
What does it do?
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's Kinda like lsd.
You have a microdose Lsd,
completely different experience than a
full hid or two to five to whatever,
all different experiences,
you know.
If you take like a key bomp a key bump
for people with a lack of the
terminology would just be like the end
of a keys worth a bag.
You just curl,
snort,
and um,
it's very relaxing.
You want to move.
But you know,
if you push the envelope a little bit
because it's disuse disassociated,
it's very disorienting.
Like you can like,
I don't know where the fuck I am or
what's going on.
Some,
if you go really far,
it's,
it's similar to injecting it where you
go in the k hole and you're kind of
paralyzed and close your eyes.
You're in a different spot.
Oh,
you're in a spot.
But the psychedelic
trip from that,
you were in a different spot.
Like you're in a different place.
Like psychedelic.
Yeah.
Like you could be,
I mean,
for,
for 30 to 45 minutes,
you could be in a vision,
you know,
you could be elsewhere.
Your consciousness is not in your body.
That's the key.
Yeah.
That's the key hole.
Um,
the guy who invented the sensory
deprivation tank used to do it
intramuscularly and then climate of the
tank.
Yeah.
I heard that he had a,
at one point by the end,
he was so hooked on it that he would run
an ivy so he could stay on 24 hours in
there.
But you know,
I was telling you about that book that
he wrote,
the center of the cyclone.
Yeah.
That was a fucking fascinating book
because he would,
he would get as a medical doctor,
300,
uh,
he'd get any pupils,
a 300 Iq from Sandoz pharmaceuticals of
pharmaceutical grade lsd.
Do that intravenous,
then get in the float tank for 10 hours.
And the trip reports he has,
when you read these,
they're very IOWASCA s like talking to
other beings and other consciousness,
dmt like experience,
but 10 hours,
not fucking 15 minutes.
And just fascinating like he's,
and as a doctor,
so with detailed in his ex explanation
of what he's seeing,
what it means to him.
Pretty fucking cool.
If that's an experience that once you
know that you can have,
I don't know that if I,
I,
I would have a real hard time fitting
into regular life if I knew that I could
just have that 10 hours,
like the DMT flash of 15 minutes of the
weirdest interactions with whatever they
are,
whatever those things are.
When you come back,
imagine that for 10 hours it might,
you know,
invite like just change everything about
your perceptions of life.
You might just give up on civilization
and move to the forest or something.
You might,
and that's exactly what happened to the
unabomber.
The unabomber was a part of the,
uh,
the Harvard lsd studies.
They'd juice that guy to the tits dam
and then afterwards he went to be a
professor at Berkeley so he could save
up enough money so he could buy a
fucking house in the woods and blow up
the people that are creating technology
because the technology is what's going
to supplant human beings.
It's gonna gonna take over.
You serve our position on earth or some
crazy shit.
And he just decided he was going to kill
all these fucking scientists and be
remembered that and he was like,
yeah,
but that's,
that's an odd take.
I had a different take on technology in
a Iowasca ceremony where I saw pretty
much what's happening now.
It was like this beautiful merging.
It wasn't man left behind.
It wasn't super intelligence with Nick
Bostrom where we have to worry about
this thing's taking over,
like we fucking stayed neck and neck
with it and integrate with it throughout
and we do change.
We're not the fucking same,
but we're not the same now.
That's the one of the things they talked
about,
like who's the first Cyborg eyeglasses?
You weren't fucking eyeglasses.
You're a fucking Cyborg.
That's manmade technology integrated
into your being.
That changes your perception of reality.
Sure.
Right,
so we're already doing that with our
fucking phones.
We're already,
we're already there.
No,
if he cars,
yeah.
You had this weird idea that it has to
be implanted into you in order for that
to be the case.
We're already fucking there.
Yeah,
we're there both with the connection
with this thing.
It's always in our pocket.
And then with transportation and the
transportation hooks up to the
connection so you can listen to things,
you know,
like,
I mean,
how many times you,
you're in your car,
listen to a book on tape through
Bluetooth,
you know our or podcasts that you
download.
That's everything.
Aubrey.
Aubrey ties a chapter in his book on the
day on that mindfulness or mindfulness.
So when you're driving like what's the
worst part of fucking most people's
days,
the commute,
right?
Yeah.
So you can choose to be pissed off guy.
You can listen to talk radio,
you can do all these things.
Or you can practice mindfulness
meditation where you're resetting
yourself.
You're giving yourself some quiet time.
Obviously eyes are open while your hands
are on the wheel,
or you do mindfulness where you fucking
throw on a dope podcast or a book from
audible and you would take information
in that's going to help you fucking grow
as a person,
right?
It can be into entertaining.
I enjoy fictional books.
I like some fiction on,
on audio books,
which is its function.
You know what,
I,
I love Stephen King books,
but I do not like it when he reads them.
You need the high royer a fucking
professional.
God dammit.
I like,
I like the author,
the author of these delays.
I'm reading the tipping point from a
Mountain Malcolm Gladwell and I'm
hearing him do the audio part is great
because he's very passionate about the
subject matter and he's the guy that
wrote it and so him re reading out these
results in all these different facts and
really fascinating things about the
tipping point and you know,
certain trends.
Is it Stephen King is like,
he's a brilliant,
brilliant writer.
Like one of my favorite writers for
sure.
My favorite horror writer.
I loved a shit.
Like I used to read him when I was
taking the train to go to taekwondo
practice.
I would read Stephen King books all day
long.
That's all I would read.
So I was always a giant fan is but as a
professional actor,
perhaps doing more spirited job,
I've had some fucking bad actors on
audible.
Yeah.
That gets a bad ones like radio host,
you know,
like in the next chapter we're going to
tell you why it advanced glycation end
products are the devil and you're like,
fuck off dude.
Like it's just,
it,
it ruins it for me.
Well,
especially when telling a story,
this is my thing.
You need someone who has a very good
sense of theater.
Like the way they communicate the words,
the way they say,
the words,
the emphasis they put on each individual
word.
Especially with fiction.
That's really important.
It's odd to me though that like audible
doesn't coach them on that because
everybody was saying when he did the
book,
he was a King on fucking stop coaching.
Like if debris.
Yeah,
if he was reading something they'd be
like,
ah,
excuse me,
Mr Marcus.
Um,
we're going to have you go ahead and
reread.
Starting at the top of the page.
It sounds like you're,
uh,
your mind's in a different
place.
Like they would catch everything,
every influx know he's got to read far
ahead.
You've got to know where you're going
with it,
all that shit.
And he said it was,
I mean,
maybe they've changed over time with
their approach to that,
but,
well,
I think,
you know,
it's probably completely different for
different subject matter.
Aubrey's book is obviously a self help
book own the day.
Uh,
but other books that are stories about
like monsters or some shit like that,
like what's required of the,
the,
the guy reading in has to have a sense
of theater.
He's telling a story has got to be
there.
The pause is,
have to be like a professional,
like a professional voice actor.
Those are,
but that's what you want for those
things.
Yeah,
they're better at it.
They just,
Stephen King's a wizard at writing.
I mean,
he's fucking phenomenal,
but I don't want to hear him doing
different voices and shit.
Like it's just too weird.
You know,
he's got a great book though and it's
great.
Not just,
uh,
for writers,
but for everybody.
It's Stephen King on writing.
It's really interesting because it's
sort of a,
there's a lot of his sort of life and
work philosophy and in the book.
And I feel like when I read about
someone who is,
in my opinion,
one of the greatest contributors to like
fun books and fun horror movies.
I mean he's the all time king to me.
And so to be able to say like,
well,
what,
what was going on in that guy's head as
he was writing Carrie?
Like how did he,
how did he conceive of Christine?
Like what's his,
what's his process?
What's his process for writing?
It's really interesting,
man.
First of all,
he doesn't even know what the fuck he's
gonna write.
Like when he starts something,
like he doesn't know where he's going.
He just,
he just does it.
And as he's doing it,
he figures out where it's gonna go.
Like that's part of the genius of his
method is that it's not like this sort
of like,
um,
it doesn't have a fucking outlaws.
He's going to get bit by the snake and
then Bob's going to turn into a horse
and then,
you know,
all this stuff's going to happen.
And then his wife's kind of fall in love
with that horse.
And then he's going to be mad when it
becomes a person again.
He just goes with it.
You know?
He just,
he just,
he and he,
you know,
he just shows up every day and just puts
in the time and focuses on it and then
makes it happen to what a crazy way to
make a living,
to just invent stories and weird things
that happen and just put it all together
in your head and then give it to people
like,
look what I've done.
I came up with a story and then you
open,
but look,
fuck.
Where's the story going?
This story crazy.
It's a really interesting way to,
to make a living because he's using like
he's flexing one very specific part of
his brain that most people don't really
use at all or hardly ever used.
Most of us don't have any type of
creativity left.
It's sucked out through school work.
Yeah.
We're fucking taught to just go sit and
be a cog in the machine unless you're
super fortunate and have a job where you
can create.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Man.
Got a tickle.
That piece though.
I met this Guy Decker,
who is one
of fucking opera's greatest mentors out
in Sedona and he's a fictional writer
for the most part,
but just fucking,
he's a wizard and a,
I was doing a water fast,
so I had a wife five day water fast.
Ellen just water,
just water for five days.
How long did you make it?
Four and a half.
Damn,
he's throwing up a half a day early.
Well,
the thing,
so close to home,
the thing was a science shows four days,
right?
Four days is the magic mark.
So the extra day was just like,
all right,
I've got an extra day to go.
But,
um,
we hiked cathedral rock in Sedona and
it's fucking epic.
And there's,
there is an energy there like New York,
but different.
But what is,
what's going on?
What's the donor?
Why is it don't all this,
is this a donor?
Well,
from,
from what I understand why,
why it's the hippies traveler's guide
and everybody wants to be there is,
um,
are you familiar with pulsed
electromagnetic frequency?
Uh,
I've heard that those words for
everybody of everyone that's about to
jump on the fucking Wu bandwagon and
shit on me right now.
Punching the Google bar.
Do me a solid punching the Google bar.
NASA study on Pemf.
Okay.
Three this year fucking study verified
with the earth has its own energy field,
right?
Whether you want to call it,
what do you think the earth is alive and
it's guy and all that.
I'll leave that up to you,
but it has its own fucking energy field.
And so there's,
it's not the same.
It's not equal throughout the earth.
There are places where that's
accentuated and you feel that more.
You feel it more when you're in the
ocean.
There's negative ions there.
A Wallace j Nichols wrote physiological
and molecular genetic effects of time,
varying electromagnetic fields on human
neuro,
no nero,
Nero,
nero,
no cells.
I've never seen that word before.
I've seen neuro,
neuro,
no,
I don't know sauce.
Nora.
No,
I like the way they simple.
Why is it,
is it bitch?
Just because it's all in caps and it
looks so weird to me.
You know,
occasionally a word just looks weird.
That looks weird,
that word,
neuronal and ronal there's a good book
pmf.
I forget the author,
but,
um,
they don't even know that you're going
to have to do with that.
I think it has to do with that.
This is interesting.
Do feel that that energy there,
it's palpable and it's not fucking make
believe.
So knowing that we'd be in this special
place,
knowing that I'd be with some really
interesting people and that if I was to
take some medicine at that point in time
after fasting for four days,
what Hamilton Morris and we'll call
drugs.
Yes.
What do you call drugs?
So I had 200 micrograms.
The LSD.
Okay.
And I won't mention anybody else that
had it with me just because they maybe
don't sign off on that kind of shit
publicly.
But,
um,
we hiked to the top of the cathedral
rock and it's fucking incredible.
I mean,
incredible.
And uh,
another buddy of mine who's a,
who's a teacher at Black Swan Yoga,
he brought up some really good cacau
from the chocolate,
but pure fucking get cal from Guatemala.
He made it into these drinks.
And um,
that's what I broke the fast with.
Oh Wow.
There's chemicals in that,
you know,
like it's,
it's funny what people fucking qualify
as drugs.
Cause
like terence and Dennis Mckenna say like
we are walking bags of chemicals.
This caffeine than a drinker right now
as a fucking drug.
Yeah.
100%.
100% theobromine in Krakow is a drug.
It's an alkaloid in cow that will
elevate heart rate.
It's a mild diuretic and it,
it fucking opens the heart.
It's like Ma microdose of Mtma really?
How stacking that,
why do you think people fucking love
chocolate?
It's amazing.
Theobromine social shit would have like
the tiniest amount of it.
Is that what chocolate you're eating
right?
Some dark chocolate,
really bitter dark chocolate that's
going to have higher amounts,
you know.
But we had a fuck ton of this.
Like you're supposed to have four ounces
is like a good dose,
four ounces of liquid.
This liquid with,
with their special special uh,
preparation method and I special blend
my friend special blend.
What is the,
I'm like,
what is is like a shake?
Like was there other stuff in it?
There's,
there's,
yeah,
there's some Cayenne,
there's lemon juice.
There's different things to help
activate it.
It's done the way the Mayans did.
It's been passed down generation after
generation and it's like microdosing
Mtma yeah.
And so stack that with the LSD and it's
kind of like a candy flip.
Now.
Couldn't people just go by CACAU and
microdosed Mtma well,
you're,
you've got to order it offline and do
the,
do the online and do the preparation
properly.
But I mean,
there's no doubt.
You feel different.
It's a warming.
You feel more loving.
You're sensitive to touch.
But this is,
I mean,
this is not in any way illegal,
illegal,
but I was taught how is food.
Yeah.
I've been talking to a guy who was like,
look,
if they fucking just discovered,
could count a day,
they would say,
potentially this is,
this is drug.
I've never heard this before.
This is the bromine.
Fucking look it up.
There's a ton of shit.
Uh,
this guy that,
that's on a self hacked.com.
I forget his name but he's a wizard and
he has like amazing articles on
different chemicals.
He talks about 13 scientifically backed
studies on theobromine that are all
human studies.
It's dope shit.
So anyways,
we stayed,
we take this and uh,
we climbed the mountain,
we're in nature,
we're doing fucking Wim Hoff breathing
and different shit up there.
We look,
we look the part we were sticking out
like sore thumbs.
They fucking 230 pound guy with his
shirt off doing why snorting coke cow
could be the next party drug.
Next big party drug.
Oh my God.
And that's on maxim.com.
So we,
we take Jesus Christ.
This is crazy.
We take our substances were up there and
you know this guy,
he's got like 12 books that are number
one bestsellers.
Guys get us started.
He's,
Oh,
is that,
he's joking around.
He's joking around as fuck.
He's not starting co those are key
bumps.
Key bumps.
What are you saying?
He's gonna snort that.
Yup.
He is going to snort that.
Here we go.
Let me see what you got.
Sun fucking pound it.
You use pounded out a boy.
I actually,
I have snorted theobromine recently as
the office Guinea pig.
That's not the way I would recommend
administering it.
What's wrong with the going up the nose?
Uncomfortable.
It's not that bad.
No,
I'm not.
That's not a blanket recommendation for
people though.
But this is not a dangerous substance.
No,
no.
I mean too much of it.
You know,
there's a fucking upper limit to
anything,
even water.
But you know on the mountain,
going back to this on the mountain,
so with Ted Dekker,
Ted Dekker,
hi Ted.
Ted's the fucking man and he's written
all these books and he's like,
would you like me to tell a story and
imagine you're sitting with Stephen King
on Lsd on the mountain top.
And he says,
would you like me to tell you a story?
That level of fucking writer and he goes
into one of his books and I was fucking
sold,
like just drawn right in.
I could see everything,
fucking alien worlds,
all this shit that she's got a battle
and you really see like just the mind,
like how creative the mind can be.
It blew me the fuck away.
Of course,
the substance has helped me draw me into
it,
but man,
he's a special guy.
Well,
there's,
there's quite a few special people out
there,
which is why we're so lucky we can go to
the movies.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
think of how much fucking creativity,
how much thought and imagining scenarios
and putting them all together that takes
to make,
like I saw the incredibles two yesterday
is it don't fucking incredible.
The first one we're going to mean to say
incredible because it's an incredible,
it's great we're considering taking bear
to that,
but he's only three,
so we're not sure if you're a PR.
He loves those movies at home,
but you know,
he talks and shit like that.
A little kids talk at the movie theater.
When you go to a little kid movies,
it's normal.
Cool.
There's other little kids doing it too,
and we think we might do that for the
incredibles two.
It's so,
they're fucking so good.
The Pixar movies are so good.
Did you ever see the good dinosaur?
Um,
that tells me I got gotta be honest.
That doesn't know why people don't.
If you go when a bunch of teenagers are
there or like young adults and the baby
starts talking,
they should be like a day like this
should be certain shit.
They do show the day and the kids are
allowed to talk for show of the day in a
lot of theaters do.
Oh,
see that's smart for the matinee.
That's smart.
But Damn,
that's,
that opens up the door.
If you tell them they're allowed to
talk.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's still try to keep it quiet,
but do a good dinosaur pixar movie and
they fucking trip balls in the movie.
Oh yeah.
What did I eat?
Like some rotten fruit and,
and the fucking green dinosaur grows
like four eyes.
Then they switch heads and they're
running through everywhere.
I forgot what each other's schools.
He sticks his tongue out and he's got
the kid's face for his tongue was
awesome.
I forgot all about the trickling it in.
This society is changing,
you think?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah,
it's the renaissance.
Michael Pollan said that,
and he's not even an advocate.
He knows it's challenging.
He's kind of more of an advocate now,
certainly than he was before.
He wrote that book,
his most recent book on psychedelics.
It that changed his life.
I think it's a smart play if you're a
person in his position to say like,
look,
I'm just an advocate for the science.
Right?
But as Rick Doblin says,
you know,
if the stuff,
when this stuff becomes available to
people,
it's never going to be,
you go fill your fucking prescription of
Siliciden at walgreens and you can go
fuck off anywhere you want.
Right.
They'll have facility centers where
people can go and it'll be guided.
The right circumstances set and setting
will be paid attention to.
But in that experience,
like it shouldn't just be for sick
people.
It shouldn't just be for people with
depression or ptsd or some type of,
you know,
uh,
rape victims w fill in the blank.
It should be healthy individuals that
also want to have a deeper connection
and to figure shit out and have new
perspective in life.
Right.
And Paul and I would,
I would qualify as that.
I think he's a healthy guy.
You know,
the heart,
heart shit aside.
Like he's a healthy guy who wanted to
have an experience that would draw him
in a little deeper so he can understand
it.
Now when you listen to him talk about
it,
there's no doubt he's fucking sold on
it.
Yeah.
I think what you're saying is really
important because I don't think there
should be any restrictions on something
that's super beneficial.
If there's no real indications that it's
hurting these people.
And it's all these indications that it's
helping these people,
especially when it comes to trauma.
Look,
man,
there's certain people that for sure
have experienced way more trauma than
others.
There's certain people that have,
you know,
been to war,
they've lost friends,
they've been involved in car accidents.
There's,
there's,
there's certain people that have been
through things that are just horrific
and almost impossible to forget and the
dad is a fact that they should have
access to this medicine but did it just
because like some girl lived her life
and didn't have anything traumatic
happen to her and she's trying to find
her way in this world and she's trying
to figure out,
you know,
what his insecurity or what is my
connection to these people when we'll
whatever my real passions and drives in
life.
She says I'm going to take a uh,
some sort of a mdm may molly trip and
find out how I feel about things is find
out of it.
It gives me anything.
She should be able to do it too.
She be able to,
she should be able to experiment with
their brain and see like,
hey,
all these people are reporting super
positive experiences.
What am I supposed to ignore it?
Because some bureaucrat has decided for
whatever connection they have.
Some pharmaceutical companies that you
fucking keep this gate tight on making
anything illegal.
Anything you make,
legal is going to fuck with my bottom
line.
And that's what a lot of people think.
And so there's this weird sort of
disconnect between the people that want
the drugs and the people that won't let
you have the drugs.
Like who are you working for that people
that won't let us have the drugs.
And why do these other people that don't
want the drugs think the drugs are bad?
Do they have any pot experience
themselves?
No.
Well then you can't vote about pot.
You'd fuck,
you know,
I mean that's crazy,
right?
You shouldn't be a doctor unless you go
to med school.
He shouldn't,
he shouldn't talk about driving a car.
If you've never driven a fucking car,
you know you can't talk about pod.
If you don't do it,
you don't know what you're talking
about.
So,
oh,
you smoke pot,
you got real high,
you got paranoid.
So everybody shouldn't smoke pot.
Fuck off
pussy.
Oh,
that's Graham Hancock.
You don't,
you always talking about Richard
Dawkins.
You don't have a seat at the fucking
table to tell me what my Iowasca
experiences.
Unless you've done it,
you don't a seat at the table,
you don't get to tell me at some neuro
chemical reaction,
and this is where it fits in the brain.
If you haven't had that experience,
you can't tell me that that's,
and that's,
that's what's,
what's the one thing that's fucking odd
at the very least when people go through
these experiences and Poland talks about
this too,
is how real it feels.
It's how important it is and how much
meaning they have.
Right.
Nobody's going to fucking tell me that.
My Oscar Iowaska experience didn't mean
shit.
I saw,
you know,
in one of them,
my wife and I shared the same vision of
holding a child and the next experience
we saw it was a boy and fucking all the
fear of being a parent came up and less
than a month later we were pregnant with
bear.
Like that's as real as it fucking gets.
And it manifested after that coincidence
or not.
I have a real problem with the word real
to you know,
the,
when,
when people try to say that's not
really,
that's a hallucination.
It doesn't matter.
It's the same experience like e what?
By saying it's not real.
So what are you saying?
You're saying that I can't grab it and
throw a fucking net over it and drag it
away and then show it to you again.
Yeah.
Well then it's not real.
You can't be repeated.
A double blind study.
How would you say it's not real if it's
happening?
Yeah,
and you can't repeat that.
Eight.
Is that a weird take ios good rest of my
life and I'm still not going to repeat
the same vision and the same fucking
experience again.
Yeah.
Anytime you think these different dmt
figured out,
your next trip is going to be a mind
bender.
You're in your next trip,
you get cocky going in there.
Like,
I've done this before.
I'm just pretty relaxed about my dmt
trip.
So used to really freak you out,
but I don't want anymore,
bitch.
You better be scared.
You're white knuckling it right now.
You're going to go deep and govern the
government.
They said the same thing about Iowa.
He's done hundreds of ceremonies and
he's still gets nervous every fucking
time.
He did.
You get nervous before you do anything
that's important.
So sign the [inaudible] getting ready
for something crazy.
Well,
and there's a healthy level of respect.
I think most people would run into the
issue,
you know,
they,
they want,
they want to alter their consciousness
and they'll take a substance thinking
like this is going to make me feel a
certain way.
And then all of a sudden they got to
deal with some shit.
They got to work through something.
And that's not what they had on their
radar.
Right.
Yeah.
No,
I agree.
And then also this need to control.
The experience is always the thing that
fucking sends everybody off the rails
and into the woods.
If they're having any kind of
experience,
this need to control that experience.
Like,
no,
there's no,
fuck this.
I'm sitting down,
you know,
and like,
no man,
you gotta let go.
If you don't let go,
you're gone.
And you've got to surrender to it.
And if you don't,
you're going to go through 15 minutes of
Satan.
It was with my old man in Panama at the
tribal gathering and we were both doing
a wasc a ceremony together.
And uh,
we had the first cup and it's strong,
like should people sharman came in
fucking amazing experience.
And uh,
they offered the second cup and I'm
like,
get up dude.
We're doing it.
And he's like,
hello.
And I'm like,
come on,
let's go.
So we take the second cup,
we come lay back down and I've had,
I mean to Ballpark,
I've,
there's been ceremonies where I've had
four cups and it was launch,
you know,
this two cup,
that's where we were fucking
launched.
So we go back into the teepee and uh,
you know,
noble silence,
we're not talking to each other and he
just grabs my arm and he's like,
I'm going to leave.
I'm floating out of here.
I don't want to go.
And I was like,
fuck yeah,
dude,
let go,
let go.
Go with it.
Now's your opportunity to let go,
see where it takes you.
And he's like,
no,
I'm not letting go.
I went down,
I want down right now.
It's too much.
I'm too high.
And I'm like,
wow,
he's not the right term.
And this other guy from Switzerland
heard us and he goes,
uh,
he'll rub some,
peppermint on his,
on his wrist.
It will help him come over and put
peppermint oil.
And that grounded him.
Now after that,
you know,
he's done Iowaska since then and he was
like,
fuck,
that was my opportunity to fucking break
through and go,
it's deeper than I've ever been before,
but I wasn't prepared.
I wasn't ready to let go and surrender
to it.
Wow.
And that's,
that's it man.
You want to have that mindset going in
where if you face some shit,
it's okay.
And if you have the opportunity,
especially getting fucking DMT or
Iowasca,
which is dmt base,
like to have that ability,
like,
all right,
the answer is yes.
You
wonder what the guys who created yoga
we're doing.
I think,
I think those people,
like those people that learn how to do
those long holding poses and that they
were practicing it,
you know,
there's a lot of belief that those
people were eating a lot of Hash.
Like especially the,
the earliest people that were,
that created it and they were so ma,
whatever the fuck soma was,
you ever hear references to Soma?
I don't like,
I don't even think they know what that
is.
Some sort of a psychedelic,
but that whole practice of yoga,
if you really think about it,
a lot of what yoga is like,
you have to just breathe and just
concentrate on maintaining the pose.
You have to put yourself into this like
surrender zone.
You know,
you can't like fight a position.
He just Kinda Kinda accepted and just
concentrate on breathing and hold it as
long as you can until your body starts
giving out.
And then you let it go again.
But I think that prepares you in some
way to let go in psychedelic
experiences.
I think that people that don't have any,
um,
if you don't have any kind of physical
altercation with your body,
there's no like moment where you're
like,
come on man,
come on Bri,
Bri,
go,
go.
If you don't have any of those,
if he never,
I mean,
I don't give a fuck what you're doing,
whether it's a spin class or just,
if you never have anything where you're
pushing yourself when you don't want to
do it,
but you make yourself do it and then you
did it.
If you don't have those,
like those little moments where you
overcame something that feels
uncomfortable,
then those,
those bends in the trip road or scary
dark because you don't have any success
in coming back from bad states.
You don't have any success from and
coming back from like feeling really
scared or feeling really nervous like
those build up a database if you don't
have a lot of success in doing those are
especially a success and getting your
body to just fucking relax,
just fucking relax.
It's just a broken leg.
If you don't have that in you like it's,
it's probably real hard to navigate some
of the darker roads of a where you just
have to just have a,
just kind of just breathe and just try
to stay as calm as you can.
Let an embrace you as calm as you can.
Well,
I think that it,
it works both ways too.
You know like you have,
if you put yourself in uncomfortable,
stressful spots in everyday life,
like a cold bath or the Cryo and you
come and you can stay calm in the,
in the fucking eye of the storm and come
out of that.
That extrapolates out in life.
Somebody cuts you off in traffic you're
a little bit more chill.
It's not that big of a deal and same
thing in the psychedelic experience that
you go through some rough shit.
You come out of that.
Okay,
all right.
I still have my body.
I was able to work through that now it
kind of lowers the noise on all the
bullshit in life.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think there's something to what you
just said about doing cryo to the Cryo
does make you chill out after,
I mean for lack of a better term,
no pun intended,
but your,
um,
your,
the,
everything is so elevated after you get
out of there,
you feel so good that it's,
so,
that's a,
that's a feeling that like if there was
a way to do that in a spray,
if you could buy that feelgood sprayed
seven 11 and give yourself a couple of
pumps the same way you feel right after
Cryo,
it would hit.
You'd be like,
Whoa,
you just get this,
Ooh,
come out.
And all of a sudden your body feels warm
again.
You feel great.
It's a nice little trick.
It's a very nice little trick and it,
and it helps so many people in so many
different ways with the arthritis and
people have constant inflammation and
back problems,
knee problems.
It just,
there's such a good way to just give
your body just a little extra reduction
in inflammation.
Just give yourself a little jolt.
Ah,
oh.
Oh.
It feels good man.
People through it.
I don't understand the poo pooing of it.
They're looking at it now.
There's,
they're studying Wim Hoff at Stanford.
They see 550% increase in dopamine.
Wow.
200 to 300% increase in a adrenaline,
which impacts the immune system
positively.
How long of a Wynn Hoff,
they have very different,
they have different levels of cold.
They're studying at one minute,
at 60 degrees,
you know,
or 10 minutes is 60 degrees,
one minute,
30 degrees.
And then they're trying to,
they're going to,
there's going to be more science that
comes out on different cause I want to
know like how long at 40 how long in the
Cryo,
how long does it,
but we know there's some type of
neurochemical response from it.
Right.
And feel right.
Yeah.
So it's not just this,
you know,
it's not placebo.
It's not just your mind making this up
or man,
I feel really good.
I think something's changed.
Like,
no,
you're,
you are,
you are changing.
It does have an impact.
Well just and also stop and think about
all the people that were always scared
of the fucking vikings and the Russians
are scared of people coming out of the
snow,
you know,
and the white walkers probably was
probably something in our head.
It was someone who could survive the
snow that we can't like,
fuck,
he's going to be secure to be cold.
You know?
I mean that that is who,
who's the scariest people in this
country are the toughest Alaskans.
It's mother fucker.
They have shows.
They
have like 10 shows.
There's only a hundred people in Alaska.
They got 10 shows up.
People living in Alaska,
there's too many fucking shows.
So many of those shows there's,
I know there's millions of people live
in Alaska.
Maybe not even,
right?
No,
it's not even it didn't we already go
over this like anchorage is like 400,000
people.
I think I might've made that up.
What's the number?
740,000
for the whole state.
Whoa.
How many people does anchorage have?
700,
well not even a million for the whole
state,
but there's like 18 shows on people
living in,
in Alaska.
But there are hardy people.
You look at him,
you're like,
Cam,
what would I do?
Three to 400,000.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so it was probably right.
Um,
so that's like an anchorage is like a
real spot,
like a real city sorta.
I mean real nice bars and restaurants
and chill like that.
But these shows about those people that
live up there,
those are all the people that live in
like the Arctic Circle area and they
chop their own fucking firewood and
fight wolves off and shit.
Like this is one dude,
we've talked about him several times in
the podcast.
It lives by himself.
He's the one of the weirdest of all.
Like he's the weirdest of all the weird
people because all these other people
live in like regular houses and you
know,
they just live in a house that's
connected to this river and they take
their dogs dog sledding and they do a
shit.
But they live in like a normal house.
They go into a house.
This motherfucker has like this tiny
shack and he lives right next to a lake
and he lives by himself and he walks
everywhere and he somehow or another
gets like Peltz and shit and makes
enough money to buy bullets and he lives
out there by himself and he'll come into
town like once every couple of years
apparently used to be married.
He's to have a family,
fascinating guy.
I mean this guy's not faking and he's
actually really living up there by
himself in this room that's way smaller
than the studio and he lives by himself
next to a lake and he had a shoot wolves
one night because they were coming for
his fucking Mousse or as Caribou.
The whole thing's crazy like by himself.
Nobody talked to I think.
I think that might be a draw for people,
especially if there is some merging of
consciousness and integration with with
the technology down the road like that,
that kind of fuck this,
I'm going off the beaten path and you
already see that people want to be off
the grid but to truly be like balls deep
in nature where you have to deal with
wolves and bears and all the shit that's
going on like that.
That might be a bigger draw down the
road.
Right now I'm,
I'm not interested in that shit.
Well I'm not interested in that shit
either,
but I'm interested in him being
interested in it because I think that
what you were just saying about
technology,
but I thought you were going to say is
about nature.
I think there's a deeper connection to
nature if you just live in it all the
time.
I know that you get weird senses of like
where things are,
where,
how,
how the wind feels when it's coming at
you.
Oh,
it's definitely coming this way.
Like you know,
you know where to stand.
We're not to like,
you get a sense of the whole thing and
you're a part of it.
You're not talking to anybody.
So the only the dialogue you
have is internal.
It's like a,
your buddy who fast swanee hunt.
Yeah.
Right.
You get that extra sensory coming in.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Remy warrant always talked about that,
that you should hunt hungry.
That's primal shit dude.
That makes sense though.
It,
yeah,
totally makes sense.
Totally.
I found out,
I mean,
doing the fasting,
I've done two five day fast now the
brain,
it doesn't,
it's not like,
I mean I have extra energy.
Sleep kind of goes to shit,
you know,
and Michael Walker talked a bit about
that.
But um,
I can't sit and read.
Like I can't just focus in like,
all right,
I'm,
my brain's turned on.
Let me just bang out emails or fucking
read a book.
Like it doesn't work that way,
but I do start to problem solve in a way
that's not possible and not common when
I'm eating food all the time.
It just works differently.
Like all this other shit turns on.
Wow.
Now when you were talking earlier about
this creative experience [inaudible] how
many times have you done Kratom well,
I have a boatload of it.
Uh,
so,
um,
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I,
I've lost track of how many times I've
done it,
but usually when I do it,
it is that that one to two pill dose.
I don't exceed that often.
You're a guy who,
the reason why I ask is you're a guy who
is always on top of all the latest and
greatest in terms of like
supplementation,
the benefits of certain things.
How do you know when to stick them in
and like when to lay off other stuff?
Cause how do you know,
because you're not necessarily getting
your blood tests all the time after you
do some of these things,
right?
No,
I do blood work,
you know,
fairly often.
But that's just more for general health
and wellness.
It's not to see how things are impacting
me,
you know?
Do,
do you like have a detailed analysis of
like what you were taking and the days
before blood work and then compare it to
times?
We're not taking those things.
Most of the thing,
the thing that has the biggest impact on
my blood work as if I'm in Ketosis or
not,
you know,
there's,
there's no fucking doubt.
And that's also genetic.
You know,
it's not the fucking right diet for
everyone.
Um,
that's a pain the ass to here.
Like,
well,
what the fuck the right one for me,
man.
You got to figure that out.
You know,
and wired to eat.
It's a game changer.
It really is very good.
But you gotta,
you gotta do your fucking homework.
You know what I'm saying?
Rob Actually puts it into action on his
instagram page.
Robb wolf and his wife will eat the
exact same thing.
And then he tests ketone levels and
blood sugar and blood sugar levels,
like at the same timestamp.
And his and hers are radically
different.
Like she's just better at serving stuff.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so I'm similar to him genetically in
that,
um,
I don't do well with a lot of
carbohydrates and like a wide variety.
I can eat a plate of yams and my blood
sugar looks fine,
but if I have a little bit of white
rice,
I'm fucking through the roof.
Like pre diabetic.
Did you listen to the podcast that I
did?
Was Zack bitter?
No,
he's the guy that holds the world record
for running a hundred miles in America.
He ran a hundred miles,
literally ran a seven minute pace for 11
hours.
Damn.
Yeah.
That's the only thing that you could say
11 hours and 40 minutes.
I think it was the total that is so
fucking crazy.
You can run seven minute miles for 11
hours and 40 minutes.
Just keep going with ptosis.
Or was he,
was he,
most of the time he's in Ketosis.
He eats a very,
uh,
meet rich diet and he is a fat burner.
He,
he's in Ketosis all the time.
It takes all kinds of,
you know,
crazy.
Well,
he was talking about his diet.
Like one of the things that he eats more
than anything was steak.
Right.
That was like his big thing,
like fatty piece of meat.
And,
um,
when he runs though,
when he's involved in a race or anything
where there's extremely,
um,
extremely high requirements on his body,
then he goes way above like ketosis
levels of carbohydrates like androids
and hundreds of grams during the race.
That's,
that's totally what you should do.
And that's,
I'd ran that 50 k after I was on your
show last here it says,
he says what's even more surprising?
Those bitter trains and compete complete
competes on almost no carbs at times.
Carbs account for as little as 5% of his
diet and bitter insists that even we non
endurance record holders to do the same.
Yeah.
But remember he was talking about when
he did the races,
he takes some glucose supplements,
right?
Article about his whole,
yeah,
I think it means,
um,
most of the time,
most of the time when it's eating and
training and exercising,
he's burning almost no carbs.
Well that's the goal though.
Yeah,
that's metabolic flexibility.
The goal is if we've,
if we're from out the gate,
we eat carbohydrates every fucking meal
until we're 40.
We're not making ketones.
Our body doesn't know how to use fat for
fuel if we at least spend a period of
time.
And that's what I do now.
I'll spend about six months a year in
Ketosis with maybe a couple of carb days
in,
in a whole six month span.
And then after that I'll practice some
carb backloading or maybe I'll have,
you know,
higher carbohydrate days,
but I'm still eating higher fat,
higher protein throughout that and,
or moderate protein throughout that,
that creates flexibility.
That's what we're designed to do.
You know,
you can argue all you want about what
fucken Paleo man eight and all that
shit.
But the truth is before refrigeration
and before shipping,
we did not have access to carbohydrates.
Most of the people on this planet didn't
have access for at least three months
out of the year.
Right?
Yeah.
So I mean,
there's,
there's at least a period of time where
we could,
should take off and allow our body to
reset and start to burn fat for fuel.
And then when we go back to eating
carbohydrates,
we utilize it a little bit better.
Well,
there's also people like the [inaudible]
who didn't eat any vegetables at all.
Yeah.
But I think even with them two months
out of the year when they'd grow
seasonally,
they'd eat a little bit more
carbohydrates and probably not be fully
Kido.
What do you think the time of the year,
what do you think they would eat?
Whatever the fuck grow.
Cause they grow.
I'm sure two months out of the year they
can grow some shit,
man.
I don't even know.
Are there spots where they can never
grow anything all year round?
Possibly.
I don't think it's going to hurt them.
I disagree with,
with people that think you should be one
or the other year round.
Know like the same dumb ass argument.
You should only eat plants the rest of
your life.
Yeah.
Like it to be cute or the rest of your
life.
I think you're missing the point.
The point is to have your body finally
tuned and adaptable and able to to eat
all things.
Intermittent.
Fasting is good way to go about that.
Um,
and when I do that regularly,
when I get like three or four days in a
row,
there's a noticeable difference in like
the need to eat like that,
that feeling that inflammation goes
down,
cognitive function goes up,
sleep's improved.
We have this,
a lot of benefits to it for sure.
Some people are going crazy with it and
doing 20 and four and I'm like,
wow,
that's,
that's a,
but not a terrible idea.
Not a terrible idea.
I interviewed this guy,
todd white,
who's the CEO of dry farm wines.
He does that every fucking day fast for
20 hours.
He'll have a bottle or two of the dry
farm with his dinner.
Hmm.
That's it.
That's his fucking deal.
And he's shredded.
Like I met,
met,
met him at Paleo fx this year and it was
curious to me because everybody that's a
part of that is,
you know,
their health oriented,
they're kind of dialed in.
At least they're on track.
They,
you know,
they work out that you can be a fat guy,
had a Paleo festival.
They pay,
they pay attention to what they're
putting in the body and how they move.
Right?
Yeah.
But,
but at every kiosk or every,
every little booth,
not everyone looks the part at this
guy's booth.
Everyone's fucking shredded.
Everyone's got a giant smile on their
face.
I was like,
what's the fucking deal?
And he's like,
well,
18 out of 20 of us are Kido.
Almost all of us do intermittent
fasting.
Uh,
they have group meditation every,
not that that would help with fat loss,
but I mean,
just to say that they're dialed in group
meditation every fucking day at 9:00
AM their entire company,
while the keys,
he's a fucking legit guy to him.
Meditation with the whole company,
with the entire company.
How many dudes just thinking about dicks
and angry it,
they have to do group meditation.
They think about,
visualize this,
visualize those guys doing the Dick
exercises nonstop with the weights to be
like,
with my Dick look,
or it wasn't circumcised.
What would it look like?
A picture,
they'd probably,
it probably added half an inch or he
could just shoot stem cells into it,
like Greenfield to get the half inch.
Those guys who are doing those,
like is that a mandatory thing?
Do you have to do it to work at the
company?
To the group meditation?
I think it's,
I think it's a requirement.
Yeah,
that'd be annoying if I think it'd be
good once you fucking got into it.
Maybe even if you didn't learn how,
but maybe like fucking meditation.
If somebody carved out like we're going
it on,
it's fucking amazing.
Cause were not only allowed to work out
on the clock,
but we're encouraged to.
That's encouraged to use a sauna.
We're encouraged,
we,
there's a fucking meditation room that
I'll go hit and meditate for 30 minutes.
Like I'm outside with my shirt off
barefoot doing Tai Chi and weird shit
dude all the time.
And that's okay.
Right.
So that culture that's created there is
awesome.
There's nap pods at Google for a fucking
reason.
Right?
So if you had that scheduled in to where
you were going to meditate every fucking
day on the clock and you knew like,
this is my time to rest and and just
get,
get silent.
I think over time you'd buy into that
over time.
You'd learn how or you would say,
I'm a fucking accountant and I came to
this building to work,
not to have some fucking cult member,
asshole guru who try it was probably
just trying to fuck everybody thought
down the street.
When I can meditate,
I meditate on my own time.
What the fuck?
I'm here to work.
He said,
I need that extra 10 minutes.
He told me most of the people in his
companies still have a meditation
practice outside off the clock.
I would tell him that too if I wanted to
raise,
you know what?
You know,
I met a tape for four hours when I'm out
of here,
Bro.
I meditate about you and how amazing an
amazing leader you are,
just so,
oh my gosh.
Yeah,
man.
I think it's a great idea.
I just think there's be some people that
would,
well,
I guess if you let them know before they
took the job,
hey man,
the only thing we requires,
10 minutes of meditation every day.
You cool with that?
Yeah.
I'll take it.
But what if you,
you know,
like I think people,
people gravitate towards that.
There's likeminded individuals that
every fucking company,
unless you just,
I need money.
And usually those people get weeded out
of the equation.
Right.
Well on,
it's a great example of that.
When you go there,
everybody's super positive fit,
very friendly,
very friendly environment.
Like there's no dickie,
they all fucking enjoy what they're
doing to,
and if they don't,
they see themselves out.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I think having,
there's no company you're ever going to
work at.
We're a 100% of the people are fucking
dialed in and they're all on the same
page and know we're going to change the
world.
It doesn't work that way.
But if you have a high percentage that
are,
that are doing that,
that's why how you see big changes
happen.
Yeah.
When you get a hundred employees,
I mean,
you're going to have a little chaos a
little bit.
You know,
you're going to have that,
you're going to have Jewish agenda to
mike in front of everybody.
You're going to have that.
You're going to have craziness,
you know,
have people that don't work together
well,
we don't like each other because of
preexisting biases because of who knows,
whatever the fuck it is.
They remind them of an X.
People are weird getting men and women
to work together.
Just this to pull that off alone.
Whew.
You know?
Yeah.
We got hr now at on it.
That's interesting.
What's that like?
I don't know.
I don't have a comparison because it's
my first real job where I get to play an
adult.
So you have a person who's hired to make
sure that no shenanigans take place well
just to create a pipeline for people to
talk to one another or you know,
a pipeline where you can handle things,
um,
in a,
in an inappropriate manner.
So if someone takes offense to something
and we all had to go through this
fucking ridiculous and Hilarious,
like 1990 video on,
uh,
you know,
harassment in the workforce,
Shit like that.
I had to watch those for a couple of
different TV shows when you,
when they started TV show off.
It's one of the things they do in the
beginning.
They,
everybody has to go there and we all sat
in the bleachers.
Like we were there for a,
a,
a show taping and they pull the screen
down and they played us this video on
harassment.
Weinstein didn't watch it.
I guess he did.
He's just know Weinstein character in
that video,
shockingly.
Tom Tata,
right?
It is,
yeah.
If you,
uh,
what does that mean?
I don't know if that works.
I guess maybe it works in that people
know they can't get away with stuff.
Well,
no,
it's just,
it's a safe place for people to come
talk and it doesn't mean like,
oh,
what I mean.
I mean,
those videos,
oh,
the videos don't do shit.
They're fucking,
they work.
They're comical.
Who's gonna like say,
man,
I was brought to sexually harass this
chip,
but that fucking videos got me thinking.
Nobody would say that.
I think people bite by bite their lip a
little bit though he thinks it can be
repercussions.
Like you don't want to,
I want to fuck and was my job.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
for sure.
I definitely don't want to lose my,
I wouldn't want to lose my job if it
wasn't on it because I have a family,
but I definitely don't want to lose this
job because it's fucking amazing.
You know?
It's an amazing thing to be a part of.
I don't think that it's a,
Oh man,
what am I trying to say here?
Just no room for fun with people anymore
though.
That's the fuck initial problem is if
you want to cut all sexual harassment,
which we all do.
You don't want to cut fun,
but how do you,
you know,
especially like a guy who's saying
something that he thinks is funny to a
girl and it just really hurts her
feelings and he was just trying to be
funny.
Like that's in her eyes,
sexual harassment in his eyes.
It's a joke.
Well it's even when everybody's eyes is
a disaster.
Yeah.
Any,
and it,
it,
it goes into all things like,
uh,
I fuck with Aubrey's assistant a lot.
Ian,
he's a good buddy of mine and I,
you know,
I treat him like my little brother
sometimes.
So,
but at this joke it is always a joke.
Yeah.
And so we had this team meeting on the
Jujitsu mats and he's sitting next to me
and the second we broke after the
meeting,
I just fucking got on a leg.
I started cranking,
like,
we're on the fucking match,
pitch your mind.
And I'm digging my knees into his Shin,
like doing some,
you know,
like dirty Jujitsu and I forgot the leg
I was on,
he had just fucked up in soccer.
So he,
I mean,
dude's like,
he's,
he's on fucking crutches for a minute,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm,
I would clown them a little bit about
being on crutches and here comes the
gimp and is my boy.
And then I realized after watching this
video,
I'm like,
oh,
that's just as illegal as sexual
harassment.
And so,
you know,
I'd,
I'd make a joke about that too.
Like,
you know,
Ian,
nobody's allowed to make fun of you for
being disabled.
That's against the law.
And you can go to hr for that.
So if anybody does that,
you know,
you can go see something,
it's okay.
And that was kind of our,
you know,
I mean,
he's five Joe,
he's my fucking boy.
So I can do that.
But that's still illegal.
Yeah.
And that I should be saying to you right
now.
Well see the thing is if you have good
friends,
you're like,
it's what we were talking about earlier
with like Comedians,
good friends say fucked up shit to each
other for fun.
And it's fun for both of them because if
you have a real friend,
do you love each other so much?
You know that he hasn't really think
terrible things about you.
But he could say funny,
ridiculous shit like that because it'll
make both of you laugh because you know,
it's not the case.
But if you thought it any way,
it was the case that you really were
like mocking him in any way,
then it would never be funny.
But because you never capable of that.
It's very funny.
And I don't think,
I think the real issue comes down to
people who are looking to be offended
that fucking terrible at telling jokes
because people who are terrible at
joking around with people and they make
people uncomfortable.
But there's some people in the room that
won't laugh at anything.
You know?
It's true.
Fucking looking for shit.
Right.
And there's the question,
right?
If you have a company like how the fuck
do decide who to hire and not to hire
because you don't know these people in
the beginning.
Like sometimes people are one thing and
then they get a little power and then
they become something different.
They just become a different thing.
And then they get like ambitious or who
knows that life changes in some way and
then they get aggressive and then
they're,
they're different person.
Like,
Hey,
who are you that we hired five years
ago?
Now we have to figure out a fucking exit
strategy to get you out of the company.
Fuck.
You know,
I've seen many friends go sideways on
situations like that where they started
doing business together and then the
business takes off or it doesn't take
off and whatever,
they're,
they're stuck together and then they're
not the same person who they were 10
years ago when they started this fucking
thing.
So there's all this weirdness and
resentment and you know,
well,
hopefully no one's the same person they
were 10 years ago.
Hopefully you fucking grow and it's a
positive thing or it's not always the
case.
Could be you growing and them not or
them and you not,
I mean,
it's not uniform either.
That's the other thing.
It's like if you find like minded
people,
the great thing about it is everyone's
trying their best to be a good person to
be,
to take care of their body.
They're trying their best.
There's going to be some hills and
valleys and ups and downs,
but for the most part,
the thought process is about trying to
be your best always,
right?
If you're around those people,
like everybody's going to be okay.
But if you're around the people that are
fucking super negative about stuff and
always sabotaging the life and always
fucking up things for friends around
them and always ruining this and fucking
up that,
oh,
that can be exhausting,
that can steal your DNA,
that steals your fucking,
the,
the whatever it is that makes you a
person,
that feeling that you can when you're
around someone that's just fucking up
all the time where you're like,
oh,
it's exhausting.
It's kind of the deal to where he just,
you know,
if it is family or somebody care about,
just love them at a distance.
You know,
you've got to remove yourself from that.
You can't get wrapped up this,
there are certain family members that
they go crazy and you can't get wrapped
up.
They'll,
they'll take you down,
they'll take you down with them.
You can't live two lives simultaneously.
You do your best if people want to go
crazy.
And that's always been my,
my real fear and concern that when,
um,
someone that I know well does the drug
thing goes down the drug,
the drug hole,
the wall,
you know,
like you see like something like what
are you doing man?
Are you doing [inaudible] and Tao?
No,
I'm not doing nothing.
And you're like,
oh no,
we got,
we got a tweaker over here.
We lost a homeboy.
He's tweaking.
He's,
he's not even himself.
And then when I was going to lie to us
about whether or not he's taken math,
yeah,
I've seen shit like that in college.
Lost a friend of heroin a while,
lost two friends to heroin,
gain one back and he got fucking clean.
It's not fun.
That's the rough one.
To witness people that are willing to
stick a needle in their arm right into
the vein.
There's the romantic thing about it to
some people that this is the ultimate
fuck you to safety.
You know the,
the fuck you to the standard norms the
society's put on you and you stick that
needle in you and just,
ah,
untie that strap fucking crazy.
What a crazy thing to do.
Ari Shaffir had a good point on that
though.
He was looking at a,
I forget what he was talking about it,
but he said he saw a homeless man and he
realized the guy was on some fucked up
drugs and he was like,
oh,
I get it.
You were just introduced to the wrong
drugs is already does a lot of drugs,
but he has drugs that help elevate him
and lift him to a new spot and give them
new perspective and hope and joy and
this other guy just got fucking suck
deep down the rabbit hole in the wrong
direction.
Wow.
Yeah.
I think in some ways that's true,
but in some ways they liked the heroin
better.
You know?
Who was it that had that statement about
heroin?
There was,
there was a,
I'm not going to remember it,
but there was a fascinating statement
about heroin killing you that what the,
when it was killing you,
you,
I think it was lenny bruce talking about
it,
but that it was,
it was such a sweet death.
I really forget the quote because heroin
is something I,
it freaks me out so much.
I don't even like reading too much about
it.
I like read a few things here or about
people that are hooked on it.
It just,
it creeps me out so much.
It's,
it's almost like I'm reading about
demonic possession and in a way I think
it is and the way,
I think when people lose their entire
life to some pills,
they can't stop.
They lose their family and lose their
job and they just can't stop.
They keep taking it.
How is that really any different in
terms of the overall results and the
effect it has on your loved ones and
your friends and your family and
yourself?
How's that?
Any different than just a really evil
demon that t talks you into staying home
all day and makes you throw up and it's
just fucking with you all day and making
you tired.
Just dragging you to the ground,
making you fall asleep right in front of
the sink.
How was any,
if there was a demon doing that,
you're like,
oh my God,
look at him.
He's possessed by a demon.
It'd be horrible if we just saw some kid
who was just his,
his,
his body's all fucked up cause he's a
demon inside of them controlling it.
But instead we're like,
oh no,
he's all fucked up cause he shot up.
He shot up.
Well,
they'll,
it's the same thing.
Yeah.
It grabs people.
That's the fucking problem though,
is that you look at that.
That's it.
I'll die young,
but it's like kissing God.
That was his expression of it.
And who died of a morphine overdose on
August 3rd,
1966,
man.
Ooh.
He's,
um,
from in my line of work,
that's the,
that's,
that's the Lucy,
you know,
that primordial or whatever would it,
how would you recall a prehistoric human
human owned hominoid?
What was Lucy that was that I remember
when they discovered pithy kiss or
something like that.
Yeah.
That's what Lenny Bruce is.
And a lot second you said Lucy.
I was thinking to Lsd,
but,
oh,
I know what you're talking about.
LSD.
They are,
uh,
lucy was on the cover of Nat Geo,
right?
Yeah.
It was like one of the first,
like early human skeletons that they
had.
I think there's some controversy
attached to that thing too,
which there always is to those ancient
humans that they find,
you know,
you find a fucking human from.
How long ago was Lucy?
How many?
2 million.
2.92
point 9 million.
Let me see a picture that was us just
2.9
million years ago.
What the fuck?
That's crazy.
Would you fuck lucy if I had to for the
good of the human race,
if we need to make people who was asking
if they would fucking Neanderthal,
uh,
was,
who was it you,
the answer is yes.
The answer's fucking yes.
It happened.
What I mean when it's functioning and
it's all,
what I mean by Lenny Bruce was this is
like,
he's the first,
he's not like primitive.
I mean he was like super advanced,
but he was the very first version of
that.
The very first version of a real standup
comedian like that.
Everybody,
all lines come from Lenny Bruce.
I mean,
there's a bunch of his contemporaries
that were really good too.
And there's a bunch of people from that
era that we're just all innovative and
interesting thinkers in the all I'm sure
fed off of each other.
But Lenny Bruce is almost like Lucy.
She's like,
he's almost like the first,
I'll try it.
He's like the first real standup comic,
you know,
like we'd say,
look,
okay,
I get Mark Twain was doing it.
I understand that all these different
people had like a kind of comical way of
talking in front of people.
But there was something about the way he
was analyzing and breaking down society
on stage.
That was,
this was the first of those.
So you watch that and go,
wow,
that's um,
that's like some,
it's like a,
almost like a scientific discovery.
It's like,
well this is now,
this is going to shift the culture this
way because now people are going to be
mocking things for free entertainment.
So the,
the other side's going to get way more
mocking.
So you're going to have your serious
side,
but there's going to be,
is a business and making fun of it.
Now there's a new thing,
now this is a new thing.
And that's what that guy was just kind
of a trip and you really stop and think
about how influential one person can be.
You know that one person with some crazy
amount of talents and weird way of
looking at things can shift like all
across from right now.
This,
this guy right here,
man,
he was a,
he was doing things,
play some of this man.
I got it.
I'm going to get a whole bunch of new
suit.
Dumb,
stupid tenure.
You're welcome her closet.
You can't even breathe.
I get a kick that like the hang out man.
I'll get it.
Okay.
Love Vodka Party.
That's monopod.
Chapati swing it up all up.
I get it.
I got a chicken like to drink when my
wife,
she'll use to look good standing up
against this thing.
She had the lowest though.
I really put her down.
No,
no.
I really miss her.
I don't want them shot chick that can
coat carol.
Act and walk with boys.
I just want to hear my lady say get up
and fix the thing.
It still making noise all alone.
All alone.
Like on their side.
The dog.
What has the bone all but it's better.
Can they all alone no more taking out
the garbage here.
Her on the phone.
I gave her everything,
even my mother's ring,
but to me she was so pulling some times
I wished that she worked at,
but it probably take her two hours to
get ready.
What the fuck this is probably like,
I would have to guess like 1960 what
year was that?
Did say?
Hmm.
Wonder when that was.
It's gotta be somewhere in that
neighborhood.
But that guy and big heroin problem,
man,
big,
big heroin problem.
And he was also fighting against
censorship.
He was like one of the first people that
was a public speaker that was
challenging.
The idea is a censorship in court.
He was getting arrested for doing this
nightclub performances and saying
certain words,
you know,
and he was talking about how ridiculous
it is to put all the power in these
words,
including racist words.
Nobody was doing anything like this back
then.
It was crazy shit.
And a lot of what he was doing,
um,
to me,
you know,
sanity.
Yeah.
A lot of what he was doing was he was a
big believer and expanding his
consciousness.
He was getting fucked up a lot.
He's,
you know,
he's doing obviously doing heroin
because he died of it,
talked about it pretty openly,
but who knows what else he was doing to,
I think marijuana was involved in there
too.
He's expanding his mind and it's strange
time.
I think it's impossible for us to really
put ourselves in the mindset of people
who lived in the 1950s in 19 early 1960s
I think.
I don't even think we're capable of
doing it now.
We have like a vh one depiction of that.
Did you ever see the the decades?
Yeah.
Where they had been through the sixties
the seventies eighties and nineties that
was pretty fucking Rad,
but that's still a Hollywood version of
it.
100% you know,
even when they get to the eighties you
know like go canes are surgeons and it's
all fucking Madonna and prince and it's
so silly back to the future and shit
like that.
I don't think we can imagine what it
would have been like growing up then.
You know,
living in his era,
like people were so buttoned down to
have some guy come along and go,
why,
why are we doing it like this now?
He was,
um,
that's a crazy thing that standup comedy
started in America.
It really did.
I mean there was definitely gestures and
you know,
King Arthur's days and all that
bullshit.
And from the beginning of time people
have had court jesters and there's
always been funny people in the village
that everybody gathered round like a
Joey Diaz type character that lives
somewhere.
But this,
the art of stand up comedy,
like that was the first,
and I,
I think,
I mean maybe I'm wrong,
maybe it's Mark Twain,
but if it's not,
it's not mark Twain,
Tim,
you know,
that was the first one where people
started wanting to be that and then they
kind of like,
there was a lot of that coming off of
that,
you know,
like these,
these little branches get taken off the
main river and culture occasionally,
you know,
and I think a lot of that was what I was
reading in the Malcolm Gladwell book
that was talking about earlier,
that was the tipping point,
tipping point.
It's about different trends,
like real,
real specific stuff.
Like what,
what caused this a uptick and um,
syphilis in one part of the country and
like what caught,
like what are these,
all these factors that fall in place
that all work synergistically and push
something over the top.
How did hush puppies go from a business
that was like almost bankrupt to being
something that will like everywhere.
And then there's,
in two years they had stores opened in
every mall and they were closed.
I mean,
they were um,
open,
uh,
for decades without this kind of success
and something happened and they became
this hip thing to have hush puppies on
and then boom,
the business just explodes out of
nowhere.
And did these weird moments like that
sometimes like an elan musk type
character,
it comes along and just,
Oh,
I want to fucking put people on Mars.
I want to make an electric car,
I want to puck shoot tunnels under the
ground.
Like one of these characters comes along
and then through them there's like this
new river and all this new crazy shit
happens.
That guy was,
that was,
that guy was probably the,
the number one for standup comedy for
that
fucking massive,
yeah.
Pretty crazy shit dude.
You ever see,
uh,
what was the name of it?
This is the touring,
the turing test.
The Turing Turing test is a,
whether or not you could tell if
artificial intelligence is human.
Yeah.
It's not the turing test.
It's the movie about the guy who
invented the computer.
Turing.
Oh,
the British dude.
Okay.
Um,
oh wait,
are you talking about x mocking or like
the one about it?
Like the imitation game or something
like the invitation game?
Yeah.
It's fucking
nuts to think like if you look,
if you watched that movie and obviously,
have you seen it?
No,
it's the imitation.
It's awesome.
That guy's a great,
a great fucking actor too.
I'm right in the show right now.
It's Dr Strange,
benedict cumberbatch.
He's a savage,
but they go through that in that time
period.
He fucking invented the fucking
computer,
you know?
And then he goes through the time period
and he's gay in Britain and they put
them on medication that lowers his
testosterone so he won't be gay,
so they won't have sex with men.
It's fucking insane.
That's a hilarious toby.
But if you think about like people who
move the fucking needle,
right?
Like people that change shift,
like if that's where it comes from
computers and then we get to fucking
hyper-intelligent superintelligent ai.
It all started there.
That is crazy
one.
Well,
there was a bunch of different factions,
right?
Bunch of different people that were
working on computers because a woman
created the very first computer code.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I forget what her name was.
Well,
there's two.
There's two pivotal inventions by women
in,
uh,
in computer design and then ultimately,
and in the actual execution of it,
here it is Ada lovelace.
It's been called the world's first
computer programmer.
What she did was write the world's first
machine algorithm for an early computing
machine that existed only on paper.
Of course,
someone had to be the first,
but lovelace was a woman and this was in
the 1840s.
So suck it stupid people sock.
Yeah.
Ada.
Ada was rocking shit in the 18 hundreds.
She's figuring it out.
Imagine you've,
you'd be like,
look,
one day they're gonna be able to do
this,
but right now they don't want to do it
if one day,
if they just figured out how to do this,
this is this and there's an that and
we're going to have computers and the
computers will operate on this algorithm
and people are looking at you like,
pitch,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Computers like imagined how,
what a hell it would be to be a super,
super genius living amongst the cave
people.
You're like,
you fucks,
we could be flying around if you
assholes knew how to melt aluminum.
Can you guys get me some glass?
You don't know glass shit.
Do you have any wires?
You have no wire.
Okay.
Where do you get your metal?
You don't have metal.
What shit you imagine if you like we're
looking at metal in the ground.
Like why don't they just pull the metal
out and make things out of that?
And then I'll look around and you're
like,
what's the point?
What's the point in making a house?
What's the point?
What's the point in having glass windows
that look out at these cave people
fucking each other and stab and
mastodons and the deck with flint tips.
Tools.
Fuck.
Imagine what the hell that would be.
That would be like the worst thing you
could do to somebody.
Like,
imagine if one day they come up with a
time machine and uh,
one of the punishments for people that
were real pieces of shit as you throw
them in front of Gingiss cons horde in
like 1200 a day,
you would just like take your underwear,
you're in your underwear,
everybody knows it's going to happen.
You have a chance to live if you just
might get lucky
and like teleport to the right spot and
not get slaughtered and eaten by the
Mongols as they come over the top of the
hill.
But we're going to put you right in
front of them and you know,
good luck you piece of shit.
Fucking transport transportive at a time
machine.
I mean,
if they do come up with what the ability
to do that to people one day,
like an actual time machine,
that would be the biggest hell ever.
Take a person from 2018 who's used to
drive it around in his tesla and
checking his text every five minutes and
no,
you were going to let you live.
We're going to let you live,
but you're gonna live in 1200 a day.
No doctors,
no doctors.
What the fuck is a doctor?
What are you talking about,
man?
You gotta run,
you gotta run.
They're coming over the hill.
You know you smell that.
Yeah,
that's people burning.
You smell people burning like candles.
Ron Just fucking run.
But you're alive.
That was the punishment.
Yeah,
that'd be fine.
Now that would be crazy manage.
If somebody raped you and you get to
decide what year they come back,
where they have to go,
yeah,
we'll just send this motherfucker back
to the dinosaur era.
Good luck.
You can't,
and then they,
they're,
they're going to be by themselves 65
million years ago.
How many people would say yes to that?
Like how many people said yes.
Well,
we could do one thing.
Bernie madoff.
We can either put you in jail for the
rest of your life or you get freedom in
prehistoric,
Central Asia.
What would you do?
I'd take the death by prehistoric
Central Asia all day.
You got to fucking live.
Oh Day.
Throw me in Siberia.
I cite die there,
I die there,
but at least I'm not in a fucking cage
until my heart stops beating a hundred
percent I'd take that all day.
I'll roll the dice,
it'll suck.
I'll die for sure,
but I'll dive running or trying to get
away or you know,
break a leg.
You know I'm not going to die in that
box.
That's the craziest thing about you,
don't you?
You just decide when someone has crossed
some line that you're were going to take
you out of circulation and we're just
going to cool you in this little cage
and we're going to hope you get better
when we let you out in 15 years.
Like what a stupid idea.
It's not working.
That's how you know it's a stupid idea.
It's not.
It's not working for anyone.
You want to protect people from violent
offenders.
That's primary,
right?
Violent offenders,
people who want to rob people or murder
people are raped.
People are assault people.
That is the number one thing is we want
everybody,
everybody to be safe.
I love Jamie.
I don't want Jamie to have to worry when
he walks down the street that this guy
that they locked up 10 times going to
jump out of the bushes and take his
knees out with a baseball bat for no
fucking reason other than he's crazy,
right?
You don't want that.
Nobody wants that.
So we all agree you got to lock up
rapists and murderers and all that.
But after that,
after get to,
after you get past that,
it's like,
hmm,
what?
What does it do
to get that guy that cheated on his
taxes?
Why do you put them in a cage for a
year?
Why don't you let them work and pay you
back?
Like why is he in a cage for a year?
That seems,
that seems like you're punishing them.
Like you're,
you're,
you're just trying to torture him and
steal a year of his life,
but he'll just owes you money.
He doesn't know you a year of his life.
How much does a year of your life worth?
It's worth fucking billions of dollars a
year.
Your Life.
Fuck you man.
You can't take a year or someone's life.
That's crazy.
But if you owe taxes,
like,
oh,
I'd like a year of your life,
sir.
Or if you're fucking selling plants,
sell implants or worse,
you're one of those people that didn't
send the envelope and trying to bring
someone that 4,000
pounds of cocaine over,
what would be a good deterrent for come
from parts of stops?
I don't think there's,
I think education is that the real
determined you have to catch them and
there has to be punishment.
Like if you owe people money,
there should be reparations.
You should,
like if you,
if you were involved in some sort of a
banking scheme and you rip people off,
you should have to pay those people
back.
Period.
You should have,
you should be responsible for that after
that,
um,
you're assuming that someone's capable
of growing and sometimes we don't like
to do that.
It's very convenient to assume that
someone is in a static state and they're
never going to grow.
Oh,
this old banker asshole,
he's just a ritual cut and this is how
he's going to die.
Fuck him.
There's,
there's that thing,
but he's a human being.
And even if he lived his life,
fucking people over on those,
uh,
you know,
those weird mortgage situation loans
that were going on.
What were those things called?
Those,
um,
the adjustable arm.
Yeah,
the adjustable mortgages that people got
fucked on because they signed up for
them and they were really low rate and
then also in their rate jacked up
through the roof and they were just
inevitably going to lose their house.
And this was like something that people
knew about it before.
And even the people that organize that
kind of Shit,
even knowing they can grow,
it's a horrible thing they did,
but they used to say that they're done
fucked damn.
Lock them up forever.
My grandma lost her house.
It's terrible that your grandma lost her
house and whoever the fuck benefited
from your grandma losing the house,
they should all have to give that money
back to,
we should figure out the fuck.
How the fuck did they allow these banks
to weasel people like that.
You're not looking out for anybody's
best interest when you do something like
that.
It,
and obviously they didn't know they were
going to.
The rates are gonna get as high as they
got where people were.
Well,
they should all situations,
but they should've.
They should've known something was
coming.
He hit the point though that they should
have succumbed in paid back.
Either should've been paid,
man,
none of those fucking people got paid
back.
It doesn't matter how long you locked
him up for,
like nobody fucking got their house
back.
Yeah.
Everyone got fucked over and even people
that were involved in the organizations
that we're probably responsible in part
for the recession,
which fucked everything up,
they'll it.
Those people got bonuses when there was
bailouts.
It the whole thing is the bailout should
have been for fucking everybody who lost
their home.
For sure,
for sure.
It shouldn't.
The bailout most certainly shouldn't
have gone to.
I know that they have to pay these
people these bonuses because he's
bonuses are in their contract,
but that's still crazy.
It's still crazy.
Even if it's in the contract.
I mean,
the government's got to bail you guys
out.
You guys are a failed business.
It's banks have failed business and
you're still going to try to claim that
you guys did so well that you need a
bonus like this.
Great.
And you're going to take that taxpayer
money and apply it to your bonus.
So all those poor people out there
working $50,000
a year,
you're going to just take a giant,
what?
What's a good one for one of those guys?
What's a good one?
What's a good bonus?
What do you think is like the biggest
bonus that one of those banker guys got
during the bailout?
If you're going to get 300 million,
oh,
is it that high?
I don't think it's that high.
Got 30 30 minutes.
At least that's what the JP Morgan Guy
Guy last year yet last year.
Yeah,
but wait a minute.
No,
we're not in a recession though.
Like they were getting it at the end of
uh,
bushes term.
Right?
So that was 2009 he got 16 million.
Someone got 16 million guy.
You got 16 million during the bailouts.
Well,
and his worst year,
you've got 20 million baller.
We think his house looks like it's
probably made out of cocaine.
It's probably like a Igloo.
I walks by and licks the walls.
Here's the real question.
You give the average person 25 billion
bucks,
they don't have to work again ever.
You know,
this guy's making 20 million bucks every
year or more probably with all these
bonuses,
right?
Like what?
What?
When do you get out?
Like how much do you have to have in the
bank before you go,
you know what,
I'm just going to fucking live frugally
and never work again.
That God does not need to live frugally.
He doesn't even any of that.
I mean,
and money for most folks.
Like what's the number that you'd have
to get to where you're like,
check please.
Yeah.
I don't know what the deal,
whatever that driving forces though to
attain that.
That doesn't just magically go away.
You know?
It's not like you get to that point and
you're like,
all right,
now I can retire.
Like what are you fucking doing?
Retirement?
Look at the people who continue to work.
You have a thousand things you love to
do.
Right?
And you're good at them and you're
obsessed with them.
Other people don't have that.
All they know is their job.
All they know is to work and they don't.
They have a hard time integrating when
they come out of that,
you know,
you have to have something that gives
your life meaning and purpose.
Yeah,
that's true.
Um,
it's hard for people to take up new
hobbies too,
but really fun.
That's the thing about learning stuff,
getting good at stuff.
When you suck,
there's a little,
you know,
there's a period in the beginning of
it's frustrating,
but once you,
if you do do like anything,
no matter what it is,
especially physical stuff,
something about getting good at things,
it's very rewarding.
You know,
not enough people go through that.
And I don't know,
people I think try new shit out.
And I think there's also new pathways
that get opened in your brain.
The more you try something new that you
suck at.
And will you start off from that
beginner phase and try to like put it
together.
And I think the little journey of the
beginner phase getting good or I think
we should try something new once a year.
I really do.
I mean maybe more,
but for me it can't be more than once a
year because I get too crazy about
stuff.
For me once a year it's like I might be
able to squeeze something in once a year
and try it out for a little while and
not let it overcome all the things I'm
already crazy about.
You know.
How often do you go hunting?
Well,
uh,
it's usually in the fall for elk and
then usually we do something in the
early spring.
Uh,
we go to Lanai and we hunt for access
deer.
That's like the,
that gets you ready for a bow hunting
because they were really difficult to
hunt you there really fast.
There's one out that access is 24,
seven in Texas,
24,
seven.
Yeah.
You can hunt them all day long,
but they have a real problem in the fact
that they,
especially in the night,
they have no predators.
There's nothing,
at least in Texas,
they have mountain lions and I mean,
maybe coyotes are a situation for Fonz.
I think.
I would think,
I would imagine coyote's kits,
some phones,
but they don't really have many,
um,
bear to speak of Texas.
Although I think Texas is seeing a
resurgence in black bear population.
They're starting to see sightings of
black bear check Steve.
That's true.
Um,
that would,
uh,
that would kill off some.
They kill off a shit load of deer,
a little,
a little bear or um,
um,
little calves and um,
uh,
Fonz,
deer fawns and cow l calves.
When a cow elk rather gives a calf,
bears get those fuckers all the time.
They get like half of them,
half of the Fonz bond born.
Damn.
Yeah.
They smell it a mile away or they have
like insane sense of smell they can tune
into on.
We'll let go.
When when people shoot guns and kill an
animal,
they think it's like,
oh,
dinner bell.
Like there's a real issue with that in
like certain places where people hunt or
this bears once,
once you shoot something they go,
oh,
I'm going that way.
I'm just going to take whatever the fuck
they shot and that'll be mine now and
they can smell the guts.
Like as soon as you start cleaning it
deer,
they smell it.
Like way the fuck away from you might be
going home with a bear and an access
tier.
Yeah.
I don't know if they hear black bear
spotted in another to Texoma town.
Yeah,
there's a picture of it.
There it is.
It's fucking black bear.
Imagine if you did know that bears
existed there and you were out in the
woods at night and you saw that thing
like it's a fucking warrior wolf.
You know they have video of it up.
Yeah.
I think it's just the picture on the
trail.
Camera River.
That is,
oh,
I see.
Yeah,
so now they know.
Yep.
That's definitely a bear.
Yeah,
they,
they travel fascinating animals,
man.
I mean if they weren't real,
you know what a what an interesting
thing that would be in fiction,
especially at Grizzlies,
Kodiak bears,
you know what I mean?
If they didn't exist.
Yeah.
What a crazy creation that would be in a
movie and just seeing a barrier,
like what the fuck is that thing?
You know it's a star wars animal.
Well,
just being up close to one totally
different ball game.
Have you ever seen one in the wild?
No.
When we were,
I went to the Kenai River and Alaska for
salmon fishing on a bachelor party and
in one of the tiny airports there before
we got in,
they had a full size,
it's fucking hind legs and I was like,
good fucking God.
I had no idea.
Like no idea how big it was.
Same with Moose though.
Like I had no idea what's amount of
Jamie happened here.
Woman says she's stabbed bear during
attack in California Park.
Yeah.
They have black bear in Los Angeles.
Los Angeles,
Los Angeles.
What?
What's your shit?
Joe Rogan.
Holy Shit.
A popular park in California is back
open Friday after a woman says she was
attacked by a bear and had to stab it in
order to escape Los Angeles County
sheriff's officials say the attack was
reported at about noon,
Thursday on the Pacific coast trail in
Los Angeles area.
Vasquez,
parks,
rock,
rocks park.
Where's Vasquez rocks?
Holy Shit,
dude.
Look at this.
She,
she uh,
was hiking on a trail as you turned
around after seeing what appeared to be
bear droppings a short times later,
she heard something behind her head and
turned to see a small black bear
approaching her at a fast pace.
She pulled a knife from her backpack and
stab the band,
the left shoulder,
which made it stop and run away
authority.
Say The hiker was scratched on her waist
and her wrist,
but she refused medical treatment.
Holy Shit.
This pitches gangster.
She stabbed a bear and she's a first in
La to stab a bear.
That girls ready though.
Respect,
right?
I mean,
she pulled that fucking knife out,
stab that bear and the bear scratched
her and she's like,
I'm good.
I don't need to go.
To a fucking pussy ass doctor.
I just dabbed a bear motherfucker.
Where is it?
Is it off the 10 what does that
Palmdale.
Oh,
interesting.
That's not Los Angeles.
It's like north of here.
Okay.
Near Palmdale and bit Palmdale is way
out there,
man.
Where's Palmdale?
Okay.
It's halfway between here and Palm Dale.
Go back out again a little bit.
Where some of the streets of the cities
road.
Angeles forest.
It's right in between.
Oh,
okay.
So it's near where the two is,
right?
Just north of Burbank.
Oh,
okay.
Is that the to the 14 it's then,
but this is the five and then this is
the,
okay.
That Angeles Crest highway is gorgeous
up there.
That's where Jay Leno does all of this
stuff.
When he takes cars up there and like
does that Jay Leno's garage shit and
drives up the fucking beautiful up
there.
God,
it's crazy.
So that's where the bear was.
That makes sense.
There's bears up there.
There's bears in Santa Santa Barbara
believe or not believe it.
It's mountainous,
right?
Yeah.
People find bears out there.
You spent time in there.
Santa Barbara.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I love it out there.
It's gorgeous.
You know,
it's um,
it's a real unfortunate what happened in
this last mudslide.
You know about that.
A lot of people died in a mudslide.
Heard about houses.
Mild man,
I think it was last year.
He lives in the Santa Cruz mountains and
he was fucking trapped like not in his
home but in a small town for two weeks.
Whoa.
Cause the road that leads to the 17,
how you get from Santa Cruz to San Jose.
Yeah.
Completely shutdown.
Tons of mud slides.
That's right in the pch was shut down
for a long stretch.
Right.
I think it still is.
I think it's still down.
I think the stretch,
the stretch of highway that takes,
that'll take you from like San Luis
Obispo all the way up to uh,
San Francisco.
That's,
that's the PCH,
right?
Yeah.
There's a spot on the way to big,
sir.
There's a spot where I don't think you
can get through it anymore.
I think it's still fucked up.
See if that thing is still closed.
But it was cold.
It was a giant stretch that got wiped
out.
Like they had these photos of before and
after.
It's like,
imagine seeing that go down magic bean
in your little fucking mg convertible,
ma'am.
Zipping along,
looking at the ocean.
Boy,
life is grand and you see just fucking
mountain coming down.
Just you.
You know this is it.
This is it.
This is how it's going to go.
It's back open now.
Oh they opened it.
How long did it take to reopen it?
I Dunno.
It's been open for earlier this year.
Ah,
Nice.
Let's good.
Oh,
how did they ever,
did they say how they figured it out?
Because there was some questions is
whether or not they were going to dig it
out or what the Nigga put a new road
over the top of the dirt that's there
now.
Road tripping hipsters.
Is that what it says?
Does it say that road tripping.
Hipsters vacationing with families.
That's what a weird thing to say.
Residents or vibe by creating hiking
trails that enabled people to bypass the
highway.
Closures by foot and those courageous
enough to drive could take on the Nassi
Nascimento first and a road with its
hairpin turns and shit.
And steep drops.
Yikes.
It crosses a Santa Lucy arrange and
connects the big Sur coast with route
one o one further inland.
Given the challenges,
several tourism businesses simply closed
up shop for the summer.
Wow.
Imagine having a hike for food and Shit
and you realize like,
oh my God,
we live in big Sur.
Like what?
We trapped,
what are we thinking?
What the fuck we think?
And then the earth wasn't going to move.
You wouldn't have a knife on you or what
would you do?
You wouldn't have shit.
Wouldn't have shit.
You'd be,
we're out there with your birkenstocks
on talking about your next Iowasca
session and next thing you know,
I see that in mountain coming down on
you.
Look through your fanny packs and like,
where's all the functional shit in my
utility belt right now?
Don't even have a key.
Like at least you can have old school
key and kind of cut things a little bit
with a key.
Most people don't even have a fucking
key anymore.
Keela century cars,
fobs.
You have a fog,
a key for your house,
and you get a fob for everything else.
Fucking fobs.
How long before we were those things?
I have one in my wallet.
I have Alexis and it's a card.
My key,
my key is a card card entry.
Yes.
Keep it in the wallet.
Keeping the wallet.
Yeah,
I like that.
it's great.
Yeah.
So you always have your wallet.
You always have your card.
That's better because even with all the
keyless entry shit now,
like it's still got a spot for it in my
fanny pack.
It's still taking up way more space than
it needs to.
Yeah,
way more.
Right.
I'm this close to being one.
If you just didn't have to have that
screen with you all the time.
Imagine if you could program your phone
though to open up your car and then
someone steals your phone and they steal
your car.
I can,
I mean,
you can't use the BMW APP.
Oh,
you'd have to open.
You can unlock.
Unlock my car.
I can make a beat from here.
I can turn the air conditioning on and
like ventilated.
That's savage.
Dude.
I didn't know that was possible as you,
where you parked looking at you too.
God Damn.
I didn't even know they could do that
yet.
Turn that shit.
Cow.
Kingsburg we're living in the goddamn
future.
We are.
There's no doubt you guys are setting up
the fucking little ai machine out there
right now.
Oh that's not ai.
That's virtual reality.
There's a big difference.
That's a vive dude,
but it's soon,
soon enough you're going to interact
with shit.
That's going to be,
it's going to change the world.
I think someone needs to set up a like a
Meu tie game on that vibe.
Like they have a boxing game.
Someone needs to set some up with kicks,
you know and have someone at kicks at
you.
You know that's a hard to the technique
a little bit.
Yeah,
it's your on the cakes and all that
shit.
Like it teaches people to point spar.
It does.
But it wouldn't be your,
if it wasn't your only training,
if your was your only training,
you know like a lot of Thai guys go
light anyway.
When they spar spar Thai style,
they're playing with each other.
You can kind of do that with this and
just do it fast.
And then as long as you did like pad
work and real sparring on top of it,
I bet it would add.
I bet it would add something just makes
sense.
I mean you're constantly,
you're constantly being reacting,
but there would be no consequences.
Right?
Like you're not even feel it,
but you,
you would,
you would constantly be reacting to
movement and he would get it to react to
you,
but there would be no consequences.
So you could do it all the time.
Not worry about like hurting yourself.
And you also wouldn't worry about like
getting hit.
So you'd be a little freer with your
motions.
I think if they,
they would have to be another human
playing you though because if it's just
fucking some computer,
I mean they got to write it in an
algorithm on how often the faint works,
how often it doesn't,
like if it didn't,
if it wasn't scared,
it wouldn't give a shit.
It would just block everything and
destroy you.
Well it knows where your body is.
Right.
Perfect distance.
So it has to have some sort of,
yeah,
you would have a haptic fucking jumpsuit
on.
You'd have a haptic look wetsuit.
I go all the way to the top.
And so if you get hit with like an
inside leg kick,
you'd hear the slap,
you'd feel that slap on the inside of
your thigh.
Like Whoa,
you know,
did,
it's not perfect.
But I think that there'd be something
really beneficial about that.
Just just constantly moving and
constantly reacting to this thing in
front of you.
You would just put in a lot of reps that
way.
Gauging distance.
Yeah,
a lot of reps.
But it'd be interesting to know like
would it no when you really hit it with
stuff or do we not hitting anything?
What about like when,
when are you getting jammed?
You know when you're hitting it and when
do you,
when are you two close?
Yeah,
I like the power meter,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You learn at the kick.
It shouldn't,
it's not all kicks are the same.
Right.
Does it count the same just because you
make contact?
Yeah.
If someone,
if you go to throw a front kick and
someone's here and you get your knee up
high and then you push into it,
that's a big difference between the guy
being here and you're just like kind of
falling backwards.
Like does it know which is you back
versus pushes him back.
That's it.
That's huge with sparring,
having a good sense of distance.
I wonder how it knows that exactly where
your foot lands.
I think some of the coolest shit that
I've seen with that is like this
artwork,
you can do
those worlds.
Our game,
this is a,
it's not exactly,
this is crude of what you guys are
talking about.
It's called drunken fist fight.
The guy's going to grab a pool stick and
crack.
That guy froze there.
Yes.
Oh whoa.
So the sort of reacted to him,
but like right now the vr things only
tracking the sensors so that you have to
have a haptic suit,
but it has sensors in it and I don't
think they're quite,
they're quite that far yet.
You know what I mean?
That'd be a lot of sensors and right now
that things is only tracking the headset
and the two things you put on your hands
and you can't add more of those to like
maybe put it on your foot or something
like that.
But it's not,
it's like just tracking it in space so
it's not,
uh,
it's not tracking impact or speed or
maybe a little bit of speed.
Yeah.
This is a super crude.
Give it 10 years.
Yeah.
But you need lots of sensors.
I don't even even know what you would
need to track of an impact.
Oh,
so you're in a bar and you're supposed
to be fighting these guys in a bar.
Yeah.
This is just super simple,
but like these are just programmed,
you know,
like ai bots that are just like watching
a swipe of a hand near its face and
they've just programmed that little like
movement is all.
Hmm.
So you get,
I don't know,
I would say the long time away,
but maybe not.
I think the real move one day is ai
robots that know Jujitsu and go at like
50% speed.
Okay.
That would have to be the case.
You've been watching westworld?
No.
I'm watched the first episode of the new
season and I haven't.
I've been,
I'm an on a a Kimmy Schmidt kick.
What's that?
Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt.
It's a hilarious show on Netflix about a
chick who was stuck in a a bomb shelter
with the religious call for 15 years.
She comes out,
she doesn't know shit about the world.
It's really funny.
Matt.
Tina fey's show.
Oh,
okay.
It's not a,
it's an excellent shot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a comedy,
so I take little breaks.
I go vikings,
unbreakable kimmy.
She got into Viking.
Damn.
It's good.
Give it a few episodes and that's shit
heats up around episode four.
It's a good God damn show.
Yeah.
Season two of westworld heats up around
episode four.
I watched the first episode and I'd just
been busy.
It's damn good.
I liked it.
Yeah,
just anything that gets me to think
about consciousness,
what that is and what it can be,
and then where our futures that I don't
want to go.
I wish you had seen it.
I wanted to fucking die.
Who was the woman who plays the main
character?
What is her name?
She actually,
I forget.
Shoot the actual act or something would
madeline.
She's a beast so that the girls,
she's so good.
Great actress.
She's so good.
That was married to a,
what's his name?
Right?
The um,
the goth dude.
Marilyn Manson.
Yes.
Um,
Rachel Wood.
Evan.
Woods with an ass boy.
Evan Rachel Wood.
She does an amazing job of getting you
convinced that she's both a person and a
robot.
It's really creepy.
Like she just nails it.
Like there's,
there's other people in the show that
are great.
It's a lot of great people in the show,
but for whatever reason,
her combination and that,
um,
the British,
the lady with a British accent,
is that her name?
Mave she's a beast.
Yeah,
the hearn.
Phenomenal.
Same thing.
Like there's a scene with her,
I don't want to spoiler alert her
talking to another one of these robots
about her daughter.
And you're like,
Jesus Christ.
This is so fascinating because the
writing is so God damn good.
And then the acting is so God damn good
that it has this weird effect where you
know,
they're kind of fucked up for people,
but they're not really people,
but they seem very,
people like there's just a perfect
amount of off just the perfect amount of
like,
what in the fuck are you?
Well you get to see him learn to and
figure out what it means to be
conscious.
Anything.
Anthony Hopkins and I'm down,
I'm down to,
did you have you finished a,
a wild,
wild country?
No,
no.
I went episode one and I was like,
I don't even know if I could do this.
All you have,
I'm going back.
Don't worry,
I just need a little break.
Oh,
go ahead.
I've got real life shit to do,
man.
I'll give back to our promise.
I just that,
that there's something about cults and
there's something about,
um,
like seeing people just hook,
line and sinker,
roll out the red carpet.
Here he comes,
here he comes here,
grab that stuff freaks me out.
That stuff freaks me out.
I think because I've seen it,
seen it with a martial arts,
especially seeing it all with a lot of,
a lot of the old school martial arts
schools were very culty,
very culty.
You know,
I don't know if you've followed Mick
Dojo life on instagram.
Dude,
I'm just going to give you a treat here.
Mick Dojo life is a awesome collection
of the fakest martial arts you've ever
seen in your life and something about
these videos is so god damn compelling
because these people who are the
students,
they know the shit does not really work,
but they pretend that it works because
they're just,
they're in a cult,
you know?
And this guy's like teaching people,
like if someone comes to grab him,
like to try to take him down like some
wrestler and check it out,
it's going gonna put his hand here.
Give me some volume on those Jamie.
Okay.
Small intestine.
It's going to get it right from the neck
and the bladder.
The bladder point right along the center
of the scalp.
Just making shit up,
dude.
Just making sure that we get homeboys
mustache behind him.
He comes in,
he touches him,
hits him here.
Here.
That's how I need to do,
Bro.
Cain Velasquez shoots up.
Power Devil.
Just put that left hand.
Look at that is chaos.
Came out on Bro.
Get him up.
This is important.
Wow.
He smacks the shit out of them and this
guy really believes us.
That's an antique.
Is he moved?
He says,
bitch,
try that.
Let's try that on Hanzo.
You fucking dummy.
There's so many of these,
but this guy has like a,
an awesome collection of them.
Look at this.
The guy gets out and throws everybody to
the ground.
I am a master.
Just walk it.
This man,
they're all,
they're all grabbing him and he's like,
but I have super powers and you don't.
They might as well be five.
They might as well be five year olds on
a playground and one of them pretends
he's doctor strange.
You grabbed me.
I'm going to send you back to more door
first.
Can I just go straight forward?
It didn't even move for him.
Yeah.
It's so stupid.
But this is what I'm saying.
These are cults.
This is,
there's something about this shit that
freaks me the fuck out.
And I,
my martial arts school that I started
out in taekwondo school was very strict
as a lot of discipline,
but it wasn't really culty,
but it was a,
every,
everyone is,
they're all a little culty.
They're all a little culty.
We'll,
there's master and Mr and all that
stuff.
There's always a little bit of that.
But we would go to tournaments and then
we would see it full on,
just full on cults.
Like one guy would be the Kung Fu master
and have all the students and all be
added to command,
and he'd be telling them what to do.
And they're like,
yeah,
I shouldn't say they'd screaming out.
And she had just like karate kid.
There's a lot of them,
man.
There's hundreds of these weird little
schools that were run by people that
were running their own little cults,
but at least,
at least at the tournament's,
like you guys are getting actually
fucking compete,
right?
Yeah.
So the kids,
even though they're,
they're like dogs,
they're well trained.
You know,
they always listen.
Yes sir.
Yes,
sir.
And they still get to get on the mat and
they experience lost the experience.
Some form of fucking real worldliness.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's not like the shit on mic Dojo.
Yeah,
no,
but the,
it's what's stunning about Makoto life
is how many of them there are.
I mean,
there's,
and they're making videos.
This is the thing,
these people like scroll,
just scroll and show how many videos his
guys got up.
I mean,
I don't even know how many,
this probably hundreds.
But the thing is,
this is just what's on video,
man.
I don't understand how it,
all these people that come to these
places,
they don't ask for competition.
They don't ask to see somebody.
They know any better,
but they
always,
but is it always like,
you know,
Oh,
if I did this to a man,
he'd die.
Is that what everyone believes?
Look at this one.
This guy,
when a guy has a knife to his neck,
he's gonna Smush the guy's hand with his
chin.
Watch this.
He's going to make the guy
tap.
Check this out.
You guys got a knife right to his neck.
And he's like,
but what you need to do,
try it on me.
As soon as he gets that knife near me,
not the same spot,
bitch.
It's not the same spot.
Right?
Watch this.
He said,
I said,
okay,
I give up,
but I will take my hand and then my chin
go hand like Das.
Watch this guy
dumb as shit.
Hurry up and get to it.
Here it goes.
Look,
he's making them tap.
He's grabbing his own hand.
Czi grabs his own head.
Oh.
Oh look at that.
You leave that arm bar for Rochus.
Ferocious said.
No point in time would that guy have
been able to stab the fuck out of him
with that giant knife in his hand.
That's just what is a little bit more
believable than the other one was the
one right next to it where the guys on
his knees.
Yeah,
that one right there.
Watch this one.
This one's so fucking stupid.
I mean
retained with that hand.
Reach me with that.
What do you see?
You cannot,
you can't reach me with that as this.
Reach me with that hand.
Reach me with that.
You can zoom in on
can handlebar mustaches like straight
Ben Stiller.
But this is why I think I get freaked
out by cults is that when I was a young
teenager and I started doing martial
arts,
I saw like certain elements of that.
I,
you know,
I went to Catholic school for just one
year when I was young,
when I was seven first grade,
actually six,
right?
And,
uh,
it was fucking horrible.
And I remember thinking like that,
I can't believe all these people are
just doing this.
Like all these people were following
along the way.
There was like so off.
Okay.
Enough with the,
I don't want to see anymore of these.
I can't,
there's just two other offices do.
But he's got hundreds of a man.
But,
um,
I recognize that,
like when I was young,
I was like,
this is not,
this doesn't make sense.
This is just,
everybody's just going along with this.
This is normal to leave your kids with
this mean as none.
And all these fucking people are,
everybody's like,
stay in order.
Everyone's nasty to you.
And the hidden kids like,
oof.
It was awful.
And I remember thinking,
man,
ah,
there's something that happens to people
when they get big groups of them
together and they agree on irrational
shit cause set.
There's some weird thing that happens to
people where everybody,
this can't be right.
That lady is not acting in the name of
God.
There's no fucking way.
She's a crazy mean old lady and I got to
listen to her because she worked for
God.
Like this is fucking nuts.
Can I talk to God?
Does he know how she asks?
You got to talk through her.
She has a representative.
I got a phone line,
your fucking parents you there and drop
you off and leave you with these
monsters all day and you're like,
what?
And some of them got fucked,
right?
Some of them got molested.
Not just some of them.
Quite a few.
So I think I had a healthy respect for
that and fear of that when I was real
young.
And then I saw some of the same elements
when I started doing martial arts,
particularly with like some of the more
ridiculous like,
like really rigid traditional type
styles.
A lot of Kung Fu.
There was a lot of like,
you know,
for every hundred martial arts schools
you had three or four that were just
flat out cults.
I just made those numbers up.
I have no idea what's accurate.
1%,
who was the guy,
I think it was in,
it was in China that fucked up one of
these fake oh,
grand masters.
Then he had to go into hiding.
Well this guy,
two of them,
um,
one of them happened recently.
It was that,
that was the guy with the yellow
sneakers on,
right?
He was an MMA guy.
Yeah.
And he fucked this guy up.
The not all of like two strikes to
fucking dismantle that old fart.
Yeah.
I mean it's not,
it's not fair.
You're dealing with someone who's
delusional.
But it is fair because we all need to
see that because there's some people
that really did believe that guy had
magic powers because they run a cult.
Like these people that are doing all
this death touched it.
When the see their students,
I go,
Huh.
And they fall down.
They believe that they're getting
jolted.
And some weird might,
maybe not 100%,
but there's a small percentage of their
bay brain that's willing to not just go
along with it,
but to believe this guy,
something special.
That guy with the yellow sneakers didn't
give a fuck about that.
He just beat the shit out of that dude
and for everybody else.
But that dude,
that's good.
You know,
for that guy to to find out that he's
not really some possessor of magic
powers.
I mean,
if he really did believe it,
here it is.
Oh,
red sneakers at different one maybe.
No,
this is it.
This is it.
He just beats the shit out of this dude.
I mean real quick.
He just storms him.
Boom.
Hit some of the right hand,
boom,
another right hand and just get some on
the ground and beat the fuck out of him.
I mean,
this is like maybe six or seven seconds
before they stop it.
He's out cold.
Have those mats in my house.
Puzzle mats.
Yeah.
They're living at home.
I check her.
I'm like that too.
You're an animal.
You keep in the living room.
That's we can it yoga.
We can role.
That's hard to wrestle with my son
there.
You'd freak people out if they came into
your house.
If you are new in the neighborhood.
So a fucking hanging out with it for a
minute and the living room come on over
and have some Cacau dip into my cart.
Checkout.
Yeah.
It's like a mile dose of MDMS.
Hey,
look at my living room.
It's fucking wrestling mats.
Nothing creepy about that.
That's the mood he supposed to plug.
Giant dude.
This big Jack giant dudes drinking cow.
This fucking five finger toe shoes on.
Yeah.
Welcome to the neighborhood.
That's the neighbor.
Yeah.
Come on in.
Come on in man.
Yeah,
he's,
he really loves yoga.
Isn't it funny like that sounds like a
great thing if you were single,
you know like if you just a a bunch of
guys living together.
I've heard a hundred stories.
Yeah.
We have our,
our living room matt it up and we just
drill.
I know a lot of guys who've got really
good because of that,
like Jujitsu guys that want to be in
roommates with other Jujitsu guys
instead of instead of just going to
class everyday enrolling,
they would take like one or two days a
week and they would do like a straight
hour of nothing but drills and like,
dude,
you'd be amazed at how much better you
get just from doing that.
That makes sense.
Those guys don't give a fuck about,
that's kind of what I do with,
you know,
I just get on the mat like I don't have
the time now to go to a full yoga class,
so I'll just hit it.
Then I hear there,
it'll drop down.
My wife's yoga certified now,
so she'll put me through some shit and
we could just do it.
That's very nice.
That's very nice to have.
Do you,
do you ever do it outside in the grass
yoga,
rolling yoga and yoga outside in the
grass lifestyle outdoors,
I think it is to like anywhere.
You know for sure.
I was doing it on the Cathedral Rock,
on the LSD and the cat cow.
That's a double dose on.
Is that candy flipping or what?
How's that work?
Cause it's kind of candy.
It's kind of cow flip.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Was that where candy flip?
It came from chocolate tea.
I had to think.
Cook has been around a little longer
than LSD.
Right,
but the original candy flip must've been
Mtma with LSD.
Probably put,
maybe it was candy.
Maybe it was good cow.
Fucking chocolate.
A little lsd.
Lace chocolate.
Hm.
What else should we keep an eye on as
far as interesting substance stinks?
Substances that you didn't know can make
a trip.
Balls like now that we know it's Cocao I
get get cow shake at this fucking juice.
He Shit on Kik cow.
I'm saying it has similar properties so
you're not going to see aliens so you're
not going to see a damn thing.
It's not a fucking triple dose.
Whatever you took.
I'll take three times as much.
We'll see what happens.
That was an issue though.
The issue is there's a lot of magnesium
and could cow and I had facet for four
days,
so at three o'clock I was like,
we need to go now.
Wow.
And I fucking sprinted down the mountain
for the shitter.
Whoa.
Straight liquid.
Go another one.
Another one that I was able to keep that
tight.
I was pinching the butthole like that
lady with the vaginal clip.
Going to real accomplishment when you
could do it.
I was a hard cagle Duncan,
I almost shit myself.
A few months back headed to the Improv.
It was real scared.
I got over the top of Laurel Canyon and
I was going down Fairfax.
I was like,
I might not make it like this might.
I might not,
I might not make as you start sweating.
Yeah.
Sweating hard did not feel good.
I felt very nervous.
Very nervous.
Yup.
I don't know what else is out there,
you know?
I know we're were combined in some
really cool shit.
I mean,
getting to work on the podcast is
fucking amazing and thank you both for
encouraging me to start one.
I'm glad you did man.
You're so good at it.
It's like such a natural thing to you.
It's,
it's hard to believe that somebody had a
prod.
You,
how do you not look at what you're able
to,
you're,
you're constantly able to recite
interesting about science or medicine or
physiology.
You're,
you're,
you always have the stuff at your
fingertips.
Like why wouldn't you do a podcast?
Doesn't even make sense.
It all makes sense now.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
It's like being like really good at
playing guitar and someone says like,
you man,
he should probably be in a band or
something and you're like,
fuck that.
You're like,
I don't know.
It sounds hard.
It doesn't seem like something I'm going
to,
I'm not really into music.
Yeah.
Music.
So yeah,
we've got,
we've got the podcast and that's a big
child of mine at on it and then talked
development would probably be the other
big piece of that.
Let me,
let me in on this.
How the fuck do you make those protein
bites?
This sounds like a commercial,
but those protein bites are,
there was a crack.
Well,
something in those things.
I've sent them to people and my friend
Aaron Snyder,
he goes,
dude,
this shit's heroin.
Like what's in this?
You can't stop making them into one,
so it's actually a bite.
And we were like,
no,
people eat both.
Or if they do eat one,
they'll hand the other one off.
Yeah,
you give one to a friend,
it's not going to waste.
No,
no.
We've got four new flavors coming out
and we've been,
I get to be the Guinea pig for that shit
too with Aubrey and a few other people
on the team.
Etg Lindsey tastes so good.
Yeah.
And they don't make you feel bad at all?
No,
I have to eat them.
The new flavors are going to be fucking
top tier two.
There's something about like,
there's,
I'm willing to get like a,
a slightly adverse reaction if I'm
hungry,
if I'm hungry and I want like a certain
type of sugar free protein bar,
I'm like,
I'll just fucking eat it.
I need something,
I'll eat it.
But while I'm eating,
I'm like,
what is this?
What's going on here?
What is this?
You know your body's going,
yeah,
you know,
this is a little weird,
like whatever the protein in this is a
little hard for me to digest.
Here's a fart for you motherfucker.
But hopefully we'll probably flavor.
But with those protein bites,
it doesn't feel like you did anything
wrong.
Was the problem healthy?
They taste good,
but they don't feel like you did
anything wrong.
Yeah.
So you could eat.
That's the four of them to make
something healthy that tastes delicious.
I eat for them all the time.
Uh,
I got it.
I got the thumbs up.
Normally I'm not allowed to talk about
shit.
We're not creating,
but I'll,
I'll just give you this.
We're going to fucking make really
delicious healthy cereal cereal.
Yeah.
Like cocoa pops.
You fucking name it.
Really?
Yeah.
How are we gonna be able to do that?
Well I can't give away the secrets,
but I'm just saying son,
they were going to have some fucking,
here's Lillian.
Is Milk healthy cause I handle
contradicting.
I don't think so far.
I think for a lot of people,
it's not in California.
You guys can get raw milk that's
healthier snacks.
Healthier is,
is raw milk healthy?
I think it's healthier than the killed
off chef Lee health where they killed
off,
get rid of all the,
the good bacteria that's in it.
100%.
100%,
no doubt.
And then raw goat's milk is supposed to
be even better for you than that.
Yes.
And the,
the reason that we find out now that,
uh,
do you ever read the plant paradox by
Doctor Steven gundry?
No.
He's just fucking savage.
Did you bring this up on the first
podcast?
We did.
I don't think I had read that on the
first podcast.
Uh,
greenfield turned me onto this guy.
He says that there's a different type of
casein protein that Holstein black and
white dairy cows make versus southern
European
goats.
Don't make it cheap.
Don't make it.
So if you're going to have dairy,
go with something from a southern
European cow or go with like goat's milk
cheese,
a sheep's milk cheese,
those kinds of things.
But I mean,
if you're eating the fucking serial like
I'm doing,
especially when I'm doing Kido,
I'll throw heavy,
heavy a coconut cream in there.
Canned coconut cream.
We're making our own Kido ice cream with
an ice cream maker.
I do the same shit.
Damn.
You know,
phenomenal stuff.
I'll let my son mow that down.
You don't want dinner,
you just want ice cream.
Cool.
Whoa.
There's fucking egg yolks in there.
If there's no fucking,
you know,
it's all natural sweeteners.
No car,
no.
Uh,
nothing's going to fuck with his
glycaemic index.
People don't think that that will be,
uh,
you know,
if you,
everyone thinks you have to suffer
somewhat,
right?
But if they could figure out to make a
way to make something tastes like a real
ice cream Sundae,
like with whipped cream,
hot chocolate,
cherries,
everything and have it be super healthy
for you.
There's gotta be a way.
Lily's chocolate bars,
no affiliation with those guys,
but they've fucking figured out how to
make chocolate delicious.
And they deal with Stevia.
They do it with Stevia and a couple of
other things.
What is it called again?
Lilly's L,
I,
l,
Y or I mean,
yeah,
they're at whole foods,
sprouts,
all those places.
They are fucking insane.
They're,
they're really,
they're really insane.
They've got it dialed in,
but I mean you,
if you could melt that down on some
homemade ice cream.
That's something that I tell people a
lot is if you're going to cheat or if
you're going to eat for mouth pleasure,
make it yourself.
Right?
You don't make your own fucking pizza
with a better crust.
Make your own dessert with,
with shit that's not going to spike your
blood sugar and make you fat,
cause inflammation and fuck your brain
up.
Like just make it yourself.
Go the extra fucking mile.
Do it yourself.
It'll be way healthier.
I'd be able to have time for that shit.
Well,
you have time to make your own Kido
waffles.
Really?
No,
I don't do that.
I don't like those waffles.
I've watched your,
you were talking about them and I saw it
and they did a repost.
Haven't tried their waffles or their
syrup,
but I'm down to try.
I just haven't found the syrup anywhere.
They,
well,
you get it from their website and then I
fucked up some of their waffles with
some syrup and just a pound of butter on
it.
It was a sensational,
that sounds like a good idea.
I didn't feel bad after it was over.
I felt good.
I was like,
I don't even feel terrible.
That's the goal of creating shit like
that.
Right.
We've got a ton of Quito shakes now at
the anet cafe.
They will fucking change your life.
Damn.
They're insanely good changing.
Yeah,
no doubt.
And they don't make you feel bad.
That's the key.
Right?
Like if there aren't some,
like I'll tell you know,
plug here,
uh,
these fucking kill cliffs.
These are God damn delicious.
I don't have any business affiliation
with them,
but they don't.
How much sugar does this thing having it
zero.
It's just a zero,
zero sugar should taste good,
but it doesn't have any bullshit in it.
Right?
I mean,
this doesn't have any aspartame or
anything.
What are they using it for?
Uh,
what are they using this to,
to sweeten it?
It Tall?
What does that,
it's a natural sweetener that's
low-glycemic similar to Stevia.
Xylitol,
similar to Stevia,
but they all have different flavor
components.
So some of them work better for an
energy drink.
Some of them work better for ice cream,
shit like that.
This is recovery and hydration.
So what it is,
this shit tastes fantastic and then
there's no bad feeling afterwards.
Like if I drank that and that was a
coke,
I'd be like,
oh so good going down a cold coke in the
aluminum can you crack the top and it's
got the fucking,
the condensation all over the top of it
cause it's so cold.
I haven't had a coke and hold it out of
the cooler and years drawing way.
Especially if you have some barbecue
dude,
you're in the middle of the slab of ribs
and you'd go for that cold coke and you
just chug,
chug,
chug.
You'll feel the Sara Nay outta here.
You feel that the thick syrup mega,
it's weighty weightier vein law,
but for that mouth pleasure you'll trade
at all.
Do you like the CSEA mother fucking
amazing by them all the time.
It doesn't,
it's not the same flavor that coke.
I fucking love it though.
There were be ones,
Cherry Cola,
Ginger Ales.
Good.
They've got some great ones.
Fucking great.
Yeah,
that you can legit get things.
It tastes good now that don't have sugar
in them.
I mean we're just so addicted to the
things that have sugar in them.
You know,
if we could find healthy alternatives,
it's possible they're coming out.
They're coming out.
Um,
well listen man,
go fucking shoot some bows and arrows
and shit.
I'm fucking sorry.
Three o'clock.
Let's get this over with um,
uh,
kings booboo on instagram and twitter.
Yup.
On a Dotcom for everything else and
hosted the onnit podcasts,
which is available on itunes.
And where else are you guys available?
Is it everywhere?
And I think you guys are on Youtube too,
right?
Yeah,
we just started doing like full length.
We were just originally were doing that
for a little marketing tool.
Shade.
Put it all up.
Throw it up.
All right,
well listen brother,
we got to do this more often,
but we just did it.
Hell yeah.
Kyle Kingsbury,
ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back.
Cross a hoppy tomorrow.